so the second largest bank failure in
U.S history happened at 4 a.m clearly
they're trying to do it well they want
to do it before the markets opened and
they did it kind of out of sight of
everybody and I'm surprised it's not
getting more attention First Republic
Bank was seized by the U.S government
and then sold off to JP Morgan with I
think it was 50 billion dollars in
Federal Financing which is basically
like y'all are bailing them out again as
much as Biden's insisting you're not so
uh look I don't know what to tell you
man there's some economists saying the
dollar is doomed I'm not here to give
you any Financial advice but I think
when you've had three of the largest
banking failures in U.S history within
the span of a couple months
I don't know maybe you should go seek
some Financial advice not for me but I
know I'm gonna be making some moves
because I'm kind of worried what they're
saying is that people panicked over
First Republic pulled their money out
many of them actually went to JP Morgan
but my fear now is I'm not an economist
but
if JP Morgan's absorbing this this dying
Bank isn't that just going to get people
scared that JP Morgan won't be able to
handle it and then they'll pull their
money out of there and then run
somewhere else Cascade effect we'll see
what happens we got other big news Vice
is reportedly on the verge of bankruptcy
no holy crap no everybody's yelling
already and uh we got we got more news
than that but why a Bud Light sales are
now down an additional week by
21.4 so it went 6 17 and now 21 it just
keeps getting worse they've hired gopas
they're going to spend millions of
dollars in marketing all to avoid
apologizing how pathetic and spineless
but they're getting leftist groups
coming at them now saying you have to
defend us and apologize to us
let's see who they choose before we get
started ladies and gentlemen head over
to
castbrewcoffee.com and pick up your look
at this cast brew coffee and if you if
you go to casper.com it is our coffee
brand you can buy your rise with Roberto
Jr breakfast blend which is exactly what
I'm holding right here and with every
purchase of rides with Roberto Jr you
will receive a picture of Roberto Jr
look at that he's right there on the
back we've sold a lot of this apparently
everyone is just buying the Raj with
Alberto Jr and Appalachian nights but
more so rides with Alberto Jr and I knew
it because Roberto Jr is a star and I
could tell that star power would
translate to Cold Hard Cash
sure enough everybody is flocking at
casper.com to pick up our delicious look
at that look at this amazing bag isn't
it really great they're flocking there
to pick up our amazing coffee and you
know what goes great with a nice nice
hot cup of coffee is Jeremy's chocolate
that's right she her nuts they don't pay
me to do that I just think it's funny
every time I do so uh go to casper.com
and also head over to timcast.com click
that join us button become a member and
hang out in our Discord server with
like-minded individuals and if you've
been a member for at least six months or
you sign up at the 25 per month level
you can submit questions and even call
into our uncensored members only Tim
cast IRL after show on the front page of
timcast.com 10 10 P.M Monday through
Thursday we're gonna have one of those
up for you tonight with a very serious
and dark issue not so family friendly so
you don't want to miss it sign up at
timcast.com joining us tonight to talk
about this and so much more she has
returned it is Libby Emmons hey Tim
what's going on welcome back thanks glad
to be around who are you I'm Libby
Emmons I'm the editor-in-chief at the
post-millennial and human events right
on and of course stream sham is back
good to be back everybody good to have
Libby here pretty pretty uh sad about
about Vice
just if we could take a moment of
silence I I wish it was me instead
really really BuzzFeed now Vice
why do we need the dollar to be
successful what is worth purchasing if
not whatever it is those websites are
selling I we might have to like crack
out the the Louis XII
oh what's that it sounds fancy sounds
extremely expensive cognac oh nice let's
try it let's give it let's give it a
shot to celebrate vice's bankruptcy I
think we should give it a try I mean
they were already morally bankrupt so
yeah let's let's uh that's true see the
finals match it I wonder how mad they
will get the people who work there when
they see a video of us pouring five
thousand dollar cognac to celebrate
their bankruptcy well we could just call
it awake
listen that's what Irish funerals are
like I have no idea if they're Irish but
but we're ethnically Irish I don't drink
anymore but I cannot be more supportive
of us of a celebratory toast for the
demise of Vice like a vitamin drink I'm
saying you should all you should also
here don't don't hold back on my my uh I
remember going to like Vice parties in
New York like a million years ago yeah
me too they were fun well anyway we'll
talk about it we got Phil he's hanging
out Phil Levante from All That Remains
how you doing I'm the lead vocalist
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
how you doing and my buddy Serge is here
what's up oh those microphone's off I'm
on mute like always hey how you guys
doing um yeah pretty sure when you guys
are let's jump into this first story I
love this one from the hill First
Republic Fallout Democrats fume as
Regulators bail out yet another failed
Bank what I love about this is that
they're like while Democrats aren't
arguing the body Administration should
have let First Republic fail many are
concerned that the current Spate of Bank
rescues point to financial stability
concerns I love it Democrats basically
coming out and being like I can't
believe they'd bail out another bank I
mean we want them to do it but we're so
shocked that they didn't wearing yeah
they wanted this to happen they say the
San francisco-based Regional Powerhouse
is the third major U.S Bank to fail and
prompt a government administrative
bailout of depositors following the
collapse of Silicon Valley Bank and
Signature Bank in March it is the second
largest bank collapse in U.S history
eclipsing Silicon Valley Bank I love
this because it's like no one seems to
care it's just another domino falling it
almost like it's not news that our
banking system is collapsing I wake up
it's 6 a.m I look at my phone and I'm
like my eyes are like stuck shut and I'm
like what's going on here I look at my
phone and it's like the federal
government seized First Republic Bank
this morning and sold it to JP Morgan
with 50 billion dollars in financing
from them and I'm like wait what at four
in the morning they did this wow it
sounds like it's all falling apart and
then throughout the rest of the day like
no one's talking about the first thing I
saw was your Tweet and I was like oh we
got to write about this right away that
was our first story out today and
everyone was like oh wow how about that
you guys hear vices going bankrupt it's
like dude our banking system is bankrupt
yeah oh yeah but Vice sucks that's also
true I mean look our banking system
sucks too our banking system also sucks
I don't I I guess the issue is like we
know the banks are failing but what do
we do I feel like exactly I feel like
everybody that's kind of like the
situation everyone knows everyone's
aware of how much money has been printed
in the past five years how much money
they printed it was you know
unprecedented amounts of money we are
basically ascribing to to an
unprecedented uh monetary policy modern
monetary theory is essentially it's a
new idea it's not been tested we don't
know exactly how much stress the system
can take and it so far thankfully things
haven't gone terribly wrong but there's
no reason to believe that something
wouldn't happen can't happen tomorrow
everything fall apart and a lot of the
money that got spent over the past few
years got spent really willy-nilly like
I know that and watch I remember in
Washington state a bunch of the money
that went out that was like extra
unemployment actually went to Africa
there was like a whole scam going on
they were like oh we're unemployed don't
check our IP addresses and nobody did
yeah it's just the first Republic got
really into nfts
they got all those board Apes
in the Donald Trump nfts you know what
they were really doing apparently is
what it's been reported they were giving
interest-only loans to ultra wealthy
individuals they would basically they
were just buying penthouses for rich
people and then like no money down like
BLM seems like it seems like the Titanic
hit the iceberg a long time ago and the
rich people have been extracting as much
as they can to bail out as it's sinking
to the ground I mean that's like 2 000
people left New York 2 000 millionaires
left New York it was like 250 000 people
left Manhattan which is also higher
income yeah and then it was like but the
there were like actually 2 000 legit
Millionaires and then where do they go
Florida I guess a bunch of them went to
Florida yeah New Zealand bunkers or
something yeah just get the hell out
didn't get to Montana where they have
the the old nuclear silence I gotta give
a shout out to Jim Cramer he's
undefeated
undefeated he has that tweet where he's
like First Republic good bank he's like
everybody move move to New York go over
there pack your stuff up he said
something positive about Bitcoin the
other day and I'm like no
well no maybe that's the one thing where
it's like maybe I'll move my assets If
he if he's recommended I'm getting out
because I don't know what's going on
here but maybe maybe he's created the
inverse Kramer effect where they
actually are good Banks but by him
shouting it out everyone panics and then
pulls their money out he's like I want
to burn it all down he's just been
studying the economy for years and he
sees the corruption in the system I will
be its Reckoning yeah if you're behind
the scenes he's just calling these
institutions out so people lose faith in
them yes he's actually yeah he's burning
it all down if he'd made that tweet in
uh is in Mandarin Bitcoin would have
crumbled because what the people in
China would have understood but what I
find really funny about this story is
that there's a whole bunch of stories
where it's like there is no banking
crisis experts say it's all you know
media nonsense and don't worry nothing
bad's happening and like it from March
until three days ago all of the news
stories were there is no banking crisis
it's all being overhyped and then like 2
two days before the US government seizes
the second largest bank uh it's the
second largest collapse seized by the US
government ABC runs the story saying is
the banking collapse over and I'm like
wait wait wait wait wait wait y'all were
saying there was no banking collapse in
the corporate media and then right
before this collapse you're like is it
is it over well answer was no but here's
my concern JP Morgan gets 50 billion
dollars in Federal Financing so
basically we are maybe not the taxpayer
but we as regular people are all footing
the bill because
like all it's just tied to to the FDIC
is supposed to be for us it's supposed
to be ensuring our money right and
instead they're using it to finance the
sale to JP Morgan but here's my thought
process yo uh it's just me and I
understand why people in media will just
say like everything's fine everything's
fine because they don't want to run on
the banks so recognizing that I'm gonna
be completely honest if I had money in
JP Morgan I would have gone first thing
today and pulled it all out all of it
every penny every penny because JP
Morgan just bought a necrotic necrotic
multi-billion dollar asset with 84
branches and and with government
financing meaning the only reason they
made this the only reason this is
possible is the government because I
don't I'll just say the FDIC gave 50
billion dollars in fixed rate financing
so JP Morgan was not capable of
absorbing this without the federal
government's intervention so I'm kind of
like why should I believe they can
rescue this failing this these this
failure and the other thing too is the
FDIC has said that they were going to
put a new program in place to make Banks
pay more money for this Bank bailout
Insurance Fund like that's coming up too
I just I think JP Morgan is not going to
be able to handle it well
are any of the banks going to be able to
handle this kind of thing and they're
all going to be expected to pay into
this new fund right the argument I guess
was JP Morgan was saying that when
people fled First Republic they went to
Chase and they brought that money with
them but imagine you're like on a
sinking ship right and you're like quick
everyone jump to that ship yeah and then
the other ship was like yeah actually
you know we're we're that's part of our
Fleet too and we're like connected to it
they're going to be like we don't have
that many lifeboats we were running from
from that bank and now our money's right
back with them I mean it at this point
it really is a situation where people
are are kind of on their own figuring
out where the safe places to go is
because there there's got to be
contagion from this bank that or from
the other banks that are going to be
brought to JP Morgan I don't I mean I
assume JP Morgan is alleged to be able
to handle it the the government is going
to back it up but again what happens if
something unprecedented happens what if
there's they can only handle it because
the government because the FDIC gave
them 50 billion dollars yeah a
promissory note so if JP Morgan could
not not do it on their own without
government support why would I assume
they're going to be able to manage this
properly
not because the government will keep
writing checks so it's it's essentially
you're betting on the US government so
why didn't the government just write a
check to First Republic and keep them
afloat I as I don't know exactly what
the thought process was but something
else going on there then I would then my
issue there is
okay I think if they're gonna write a 50
billion dollar check to JP Morgan why
not just write a 50 billion check the
First Republic because they don't want
to Nash because then it will be looked
at as nationalizing the bank if the
government I know but but I think that
is it I think it's going to be a
situation of just they're going to say
oh well it's not nationalized because JP
Morgan's running it blah blah even
though they're financing or funding it
if the government just says we're taking
over and we're going to send Regulators
from the SEC in or whatever the you know
whatever the the regulating body is if
they just send them in then it becomes a
situation where they're going to be like
no it's government bank because that was
the problem or that was the concern back
in 2008 they didn't want to have Goldman
Sachs look like it was the season owned
by the government and people are
allergic to nationalizing they want
someone they want to be taken over but
they want a private company to be the
one doing it and at the very least so
that way they can say that it's not
nationalized the government didn't take
over the bank if there's an ulterior
motive it just sounds like they're being
shady and once again if I use Chase I
would be gone that's just me I mean and
I get it the reason why people like Jim
Cramer come out and they're like
everything's fine everything's fine even
though it's not is because they don't
want to create the self-fulfilling
prophecy where you go in the media say
everything's not fine causing a run in
the banks
right svb was like Twitter conversation
and then there was a run on the bank
well it's also like and First Republic
was the same thing when they started
getting hit people started pulling their
money out causing it to collapse right I
wonder if Occupy Wall Street activists
are cheering this on right now it's like
everything they've ever wanted well they
probably have all their money in Chase
yep well attempt I mean like if I sat
you down and I was like Tim
everything's gonna be okay do you
understand everything's all right it's
not your fault it's okay everything's
fine you'd be like what's gonna happen
whenever someone feels the need to
reassure you it's like um Good Will
Hunting it's not your fault it's not
your fault I'm thinking more stop saying
that do you remember do you remember at
the end of The Dark Night
when not to spoil it or anything but
when Harvey Dent's like have you ever
told someone everything's gonna be okay
when you know it isn't that's Jim Cramer
right now someone said you have any idea
what it's like someone should make that
Meme where he's yelling at Jim Cramer
because that's literally what the dude
has done I never do that I never say
everything's gonna be okay based yeah I
mean I don't know if it's going to be
okay I do I do know that like eventually
we're all going to be dead yeah okay but
that might you know that's okay that's
when everything's actually okay right
okay has no meaning well you have
nothing to complain about
but I mean like living a long and
healthy life and dying of old age shot
of my loved ones is okay no that sounds
great right so everything will be
aspired to that kind of death I mean
it's it's just the Human Experience you
know I'm just saying I I understand why
everyone's coming out and saying it's
gonna be okay but you got to understand
the people who are saying that to you
they may claim to have Noble reasons but
they're pulling their assets and they're
putting it somewhere else
where do you put it China yeah that
doesn't sound like putting it in their
mattresses eventually we'll have some
sort of like tariff situation we won't
be able to get our money out of there
well yeah for sure but if you're rich
people don't worry about I mean Panama
right El Salvador people they're
probably buying tons of Bitcoin so like
I wouldn't be surprised if Bitcoin
skyrockets there have been predictions
that a few months ago someone several
people were predicting that Bitcoin
would hit a million dollars soon yeah
and uh who was that uh that that was
that he's an economist or whatever and
he said it was going to hit a million
dollars and he would make a bet with
somebody that it would everybody said
the amount the amount of increase in in
Bitcoin due to him creating this
narrative is going to cover any
potential losses from giving away a
million dollars they didn't believe him
but the point he made was that the banks
are insolvent they're holding a bunch of
they're holding way more our liabilities
and they have assets and and they're
unrealized losses and as soon as this
comes in the next few months the dollar
is going to collapse Bitcoin is going to
Skyrocket
and then this happens you know the
second biggest collapse in U.S history
happening with two other major collapses
in the span of a couple months I mean
what's interesting is is uh Chase like
JP Morgan in the first place back in
like 19 whatever 1913 or something like
that he didn't when there was like a run
on banks there was a run on local banks
and all the local banks had their money
invested with regional Banks and the
regional Banks had their money invested
with you know banks in New York and
everything so when there was a run on
the banks the local banks the they
couldn't get their money out fast enough
to cover it because it was all invested
basically Upstream
um but JP Morgan thought that there
should be a private banking back
situation where like it was not
nationalized at all but all of the banks
got together and basically created their
own kind of you know FDIC but it was for
the banks themselves and private and
instead it ended up being
um you had like the Federal Reserve Act
so someone someone uh chatted that uh
Valley National Bank is also falling
right now and I just looked it up and
like it's it's in the news they're
they're starting to fall now minus 20 oh
my God that's gracious does anybody have
a clear memory of what it was that made
the average person realize that the
banking crisis was happening in 2008 if
as far as I remember
probably I thought it was like Lehman it
wasn't it Lehman well Lehman Brothers
and bears were banks that were involved
but I'm wondering what it was that made
the average person was it because I
thought it was because the the CR the
companies like GE weren't able to get
credit from other companies to to make
their payroll and I'm wondering if there
has to be a catalyst to make people the
average person aware if they're not you
know it's like if you don't have your
money in any of these particular four
these four Banks you kind of might just
not really pay attention oh a bank
failed and then go about your day and it
doesn't really affect you unless there's
something that makes it go
you know makes it makes it become
everyone's problem and I'm wondering if
there's if anyone has any insight on
that what what it was back in 2008 if or
if there's something very little money
in 2008 so I don't really remember at
all speaking of having very little money
let's jump to our next story hold on
this is not Financial advice but I'm
gonna buy a bunch of nfts print them out
and stuff them in my mattress
that's a really clever idea great idea
the banks will never get it because
that's a good pay use the good picture
paper too the stuff like the glossy
stuff exactly will retain their value
different nfts of your face exactly I'll
make my own nfts Drive the price down
well buy them up then stuff them in my
mattress once the price point is high
because they're your not Financial
advice you just figure out what they're
worth that's basically what Sam frankman
freed did that was literally it that's
brilliant Let's uh let's jump to this uh
next door we have this from Komo News
Bud Light sales continue to drop down
21.4 percent following trans activist
partnership the latest data released
Monday by bump Williams Consulting shows
Bud Light sales for the third week in
April we're down 21.4 compared to the
same time last year the way before sales
were down 17 it just keeps getting worse
check this out competitors gain ground
Coors Light is up 20 Miller Light sales
are up 21 that means it means for every
one Bud Light someone does not buy they
buy one course and wow one Miller yeah
that's a lot that's a lot of extra beer
drinking they're like I'm gonna buy one
of each for every Bud Light you try to
summon by two of the other ones
it's crazy that they're not buying good
beer instead but it's better than
nothing I I don't care what they buy as
long as it's not Bud Light amen the
Human Rights Campaign civil rights
activist group for lgbtq plus Community
penned a letter to Bud Light
demanding they're demanding that they
defend them
they say when uh they were super drunk
on Bud Light right like this is an
outrage
she's a beautiful woman so there was a
bar in Indiana there's a bar in Indiana
that issued a statement saying if you've
got a problem with this then you can
leave dude you're in Indiana and then
they came back a week later they were
like we didn't mean it please please
come back what we meant was you can
leave a review on Yelp and come back on
in friends you can leave a big tip
because you ain't doing that stuff
anymore man I'm done I love this story
because uh
we're winning Bud Light is so desperate
not to apologize they're going to spend
millions in marketing they're hiring
ex-gop aids to assist them having secret
meetings but they're going to have to
apologize because they are for the third
week in a row and that was last week
right their sales are down
21.4 imagine what it's going to look
like this week it's going to keep being
bad you know the only way out is a it's
an apology well you know my family
actually I'm sorry I'm sorry I don't
even know if an apology I don't think an
apology would work I remember when I got
canceled I was told to apologize and I
was like even if I did that it wouldn't
work no I gotta make an apology yeah
this is different the woke mob canceling
people was never in good faith when Bud
Light did this the first thing everyone
said was just say you're sorry and we
will move on and buy your beer and I
said look if they just came out and said
we're sorry for sponsoring domovany we
we won't do it again we we apologize for
offending our audience I'd been like
okay okay I'll still not drink your beer
no no I said I said you don't drink it
myself and I said go and stock the
entire office wow for our guests if they
were willing to apologize for having
done this and they are not in fact my
view of it is they are they're the
opposite of apologizing hiring having
secret meetings hiring GOP aids to
consult for them paying millions in
marketing is them saying we will do
everything in our power to not apologize
to our own uh to our own customers that
is the biggest Fu well they don't care
about their customers they don't care
about that exactly that's why if at this
point they have done it I do not see in
any way why anybody would want to be
associated with them at this point after
three weeks they could they could have
just come out after that first week and
been like guys we did not mean to
sponsor this person we had no idea we
are sorry about sponsoring Domo of any
end of story okay what's that thing for
a second where it was like oh the the
corporate people didn't really know that
this was going on yeah but they never
said sorry no no to be fair have you
ever been in an argument with someone
and then you realize like halfway
through you're wrong and you're like how
do I be a reasonable person without
apologizing here I'm serious ly
incorrect I am 100 wrong like would you
not spend millions of dollars to get out
of that situation if you had it would
you not be like
um
I would just apologize oh you're so
virtuous living no I'm not I just know
when I'm wrong and it happens a lot well
you're wrong right now
apologizing here's what you do you quit
drinking and then
right then you like take the steps yeah
you have to apologize to everybody
everything's easier once you quit
drinking okay because I should go to AAA
yeah exactly that round we apologize to
all our customers for thinking that a
whole bunch of men really wanted to
drink together sponsored by this fella
in a dress Anheuser-Busch and leading in
the AAA meetings how many lives have
they saved by stopping all these men
from drinking the kids are gonna write
letters
people are are buying they're buying
twice as much
they were
of course he has a has a meeting with
the anheuser-buschia he's always like we
gotta talk playing chess and he's like
you guys think you're the biggest dogs
in the park but I got news for you our
next play is gonna blow you out of the
water and they're like really what do
you do well I shouldn't tell you
but we're sponsoring Dylan mulvania then
Anheuser Busch guy gets up he's like I
have to go to the bathroom real quick he
runs he's like get it gets person and
then however much they're paying you
I'll double it none of that 70 cents on
the dollar thing I know you're actually
a man I'll pay you a full dollar then
the Coors Light guy gets up and walks
away and laughs and Bud Lights now
so uh all of this all of this that
they're doing take a look at this story
this is interesting Bud Light owners
hired xgop staffers as Capitol Hill
lobbyists the same day they released the
partnership with Dylan Mulvaney they
they are doing everything in their power
to avoid actually just speaking to their
own customers I didn't say apologize
speaking to yeah they don't want to do
that they don't want to say anything
directly to these angry individuals to
the point where they've put two people
on leave
they've they're spending millions in
marketing they're hiring these people
they made a commercial referencing 911
right they showed us really desperate
did you see what Dylan Mulvaney did
Dylan Mulvaney's last most recent Tick
Tock oh I always keep up right I
actually do always keep up because it's
fun doing the only reason I have Tick
Tock has notifications turned on I push
notifications they go to my phone
look at you but Dylan Mulvaney uh his
last tick tock instead of you know how
he does like 365 days with girlhood yeah
he skipped a bunch it was uh day 906
9601 of Being Human and I was like there
you go just be that just be human but
and then you're basically fine but the
video that was put up by Mulvaney was
saying like you know people are saying
thing in the Press about me that's not
my truth and it's just like not my truth
it is the most that that is that is
exactly the problem yes it is what
they're saying was the truth but not
yours exactly like what are you God you
get to invent truth yourselves this
objective cult worldview these people
have I say they determine it's
self-worship that's literally so if
anyone who says my truth is engaged in
self-worship the other thing is your
truth
and the truth and the life yeah yeah the
logos these people Christ is truth he's
literally he is truth even outside of
that religious perspective it is obvious
that woke people worship themselves yes
the universe revolves around them their
reality is reality that is the
post-modernist subjective morality James
Lindsay is jumping up and down screaming
yes Tim yes Tim yes Tim right now well
what else is self-care
self-care is like preparation of the the
sacred vessel yeah amen well and the
thing the irony right about self-care is
you're not actually caring about
yourself you're just indulging in
selfish Pleasures that make your life
significantly worse in the long run Tim
you were you talked about how this is a
lotion and ice cream exactly not like
going to bed and getting up at a decent
time and going to your job and earning
and yeah I saw the first for the first
time I saw someone do a cover of a tick
tock bit you know the Dylan Mulvaney uh
bit that he did where he had the tampon
and stuff I saw another different tick
tocker oh no we didn't really do the
same bit it wasn't like a yeah
that like that guy Sykes I don't know
the name yeah so I'm telling you this
guy was one of the guy this guy pledged
to a bunch of sororities at I think
Alabama oh I think it was Alabama we
wrote about him a little bit today but
he pledged a bunch of sororities he
didn't get into any of them he got very
mad he posted all these prom pictures he
has his hair really short but it's got
like highlights he's clearly in a
feminate gay man which like okay go
ahead but uh here he is trying to get
into all these sororities and then he
started ripping off the Dylan Mulvaney
stuff because it was doing well for
Mulvaney and he must have been like oh I
I could definitely get in on this so I
watched some of his videos and yeah he
goes into the stores he makes fun of
tampons and it's like look none of us
like tampons either okay like nobody's
into it it's not something we're all
alive
you know you don't want to like bleed
all over that I like what they do though
I like the the but it's like it's like
it's the effect of tampons is useful but
we don't need to go into the store and
be like ogling all these cotton products
they do these uh these Instagram ads
where it's like people have periods and
it shows women with in their underwear
with stains and stuff
have you seen those the activist post
fortunately no there's been a bunch of
leftists
Runners do that they've posted images on
Instagram of them laying in bed in their
underwear with stains and my my view of
that is like no different than if a dude
had like crap on his ass I'm free
dude it's like why should
Society constrain my biological
functions and but hold on imagine if
people were this animated about toilet
paper and they were making out of
Charmin Bears they're excited they're
super pumped about toilet paper but
they're not against it though that's the
point they're not like toilet paper this
toilet paper is oppressive to Bear kind
why must I cleanse clean fuzzy bears
exactly
I don't like any toilet paper
commercials I don't like any tampon
commercials I hate they should be like
all the menstruation commercials like
just it's always a woman named nature
yeah
but in the commercials she's super happy
she's like out in nature on like a robot
and it starts sinking and she's like oh
no
I hate all that so much and you know
what like you don't need commercials for
these things get some wolves yes you do
because your brand needs to be the one
that people know
when people think crappy butts they
think Sherman look people go to the
store they walk through the aisle and
they grab the one that's soft do you
know I don't know about what women do I
don't want to talk about it you know
what you know what that you know how
there's been all this shoplifting at
like the Dwayne reads and the Walgreens
and everything like that so I keep being
afraid that when I go into a drugstore
it's all going to be locked up and I'm
gonna have to walk up to some teenager
at the front and be like um can you
unlock the Tampa they'll have like weird
color hair and be wearing a mask any
piece of that you know like just uh he's
got to be assertive you gotta be like
hey Doc I gotta wipe my butt open the
open the cabinet give me some of that TP
that's right what are you gonna do hey
Everybody Poops give me the Wet Ones
let's go Wet Ones
actually was Tampax was sponsoring Dylan
Mulvaney which is weird and I I was I
was wrong
stick him up his butt did you ever see
that South Park Dylan with Kenny yes
Dylan came out and said after the
backlash that the whole bit was actually
to help women because even leftist women
and regular women were offended by what
Dylan was doing marketing tampons yeah
and so what that that video is like I
was just trying to be helpful and then
women got even angrier because a bunch
of ones started posting like having a
male come up to in a bathroom cleaning
tampons no no but like
and a male walks up to you and says
would you like a tampon and their
goodness and that's terrified and that's
where's the holy water and that's why
the backlash just got worse yeah now my
Hope from all of this is that companies
just stop sponsoring Dylan Mulvaney
he's got everything already he's got a
KitchenAid blender he's got Kate Spade
everything right Dylan got like oil
running for president got the Republican
nomination and Dylan represents
algorithmic manipulation to no one and
but Bud Light is learning what that
means it means when the algorithm says
something is popular it is not just
because people are looking at it does
that mean people like it and what is on
the Internet is here's here's what's
actually happening there are Fringe
groups in this country that normally
don't have the the relationship to each
other to organize in large numbers that
means if one person in every major city
in the U.S believed in you know space
lizards
there's no great space lizard
organization but the internet allows
them to congregate digitally this then
results in someone getting a hundred
thousand views on their space lizard
video
but these people don't don't organize in
the real world now you've got companies
being like who's that guy who's got a
hundred thousand followers oh space
lizard guy he's great let's sponsor that
whereas people normally are like that's
not okay Dylan Mulvaney gets views
because the algorithm pump props it up
Bud Light says sponsor it regular people
say what the are you doing this is not
okay now they're reeling from it I hope
other brands take notice and stop
sponsoring algorithmic manipulation but
let's do this speaking of this subject
we have big breaking news is a big story
from this weekend and a 70 year old man
named Dave defeats 82 women in the world
poker tour ladies event so in in
Southern Florida the World Poker Tour is
currently on and uh this fella right
here Dave she's aspirational uh the
ladies No Limit Hold'em event in
Seminole garnered 83 entries of the
prize pool of 17 430 here's here's the
this guy's having a good time
not Sports yeah is that like a physical
activity there it is mop the floor but
but it's but this is true of anybody
look men are better than women at chess
men are better than women at poker poker
is actually more obvious than chess
chess I don't have an explanation for
maybe it's it's related to aggression
and risk-taking the reason why men are
tend to win uh beat women in poker is
and not completely there are some women
who are good like in any other sport
it's because men are more aggressive and
are more bigger risks they will play
aggressively they will they will make
bigger bets they will take bigger risks
and they will get paid out for it women
are less likely to so of course this guy
won he won first place he gets 5 555 and
what's what they said is uh ebony Kenny
another uh female I believe she's a pro
poker player said maybe Dave was
overheard saying quote he could pretend
to identify as a woman because they
allow anything nowadays and by maybe I
mean 100 now as we were we as we were
launching the show I got word that Dave
actually gave a statement to timcast.com
thanks Dave and my understanding is that
he was literally protesting that they
allow males to compete against females
so I have not actually seen his
statement until now we're gonna read it
on the show Dave Hughes responds to
winning women's poker event
Hughes said he drove over five hours
from Orlando to visit a friend competing
in the seven million dollar main event
at the Seminole Hard Rock in Florida
upon arriving in the poker tournament he
was one of the play a hand of Poker but
learned the only event available was
particip for participation was the
ladies gnome and hold them quote I
figured why not the ladies as you know
are just as Fierce capable as
competitive as the men in poker and
smell a lot better as well for the
record I'm 100 against men taking
advantage of women in sports where
strength and muscle muscle make it quite
unfair as we can all clearly see with
men breaking all records set by women in
every sport across the board while
pretending to be women it's pathetic and
embarrassing that we allow our women to
be abused and victimized by this
nonsense and eventually the count the
country will wake up to this and put a
stop to it our young girls and women who
dedicate their lives to playing sports
deserve better better than that and the
silent majority are starting to speak up
damn well it's you know the worst part
of the whole story is a trailblazer the
prize was originally
4125 but because he's a man they gave
him 5 500. really messed up so
apparently in uh the World Series I
think it's the World Series of Poker I
think we may we may have written this up
um I'm not sure if we did they have a
ladies event as well and it's illegal to
Bar men from entering a tournament so in
Florida what they said was they were
like we legally cannot say someone is
based on their sex not allowed to enter
an event so he's allowed to play they
are just like we hoped people would
honor it in I think it's the World
Series of Poker in Vegas what they do is
it's a ten thousand dollar fee to enter
with 90 off if you're female
that's still illegal they're they're
saying aha we found a loophole to
discriminate discriminate against
someone based on sex does not work that
way anybody who wanted to sue could at
the federal level and they would win you
can't do that there's a dude who's
famous for going around to bars that had
ladies night and 5 filing lawsuits and
winning instantly summary judgment you
cannot offer cheaper drinks to women
based on the fact that they are women
you can't you can't do it and so this
guy would just be like you can't do it
I'm suing I win a couple Grand but but
good on this guy for speaking out that
guy ruined ladies nights at every bar
now the women aren't showing up for
cheaper drinks they were putting
bounties on them so other players about
Bounty is a financial incentive to knock
a player out of the game so if you were
to beat him and take all his chips you
would get paid extra by someone else
didn't work he won
he he actually won now do you think let
me ask you this random guy who wasn't
planning on entering the tournament who
just drove up there on a whim to watch
his friend play he still beat all the
men who actually shut up to compete in
this tournament
I don't think it's that surprising yeah
you know honestly I mean men take men
take bigger risks that's part of the
that seems like part of the the fun of
testosterone it's science it's like
there's a little bit of fearlessness
there small brain I don't think it's
that I wouldn't say small brain but uh
well you could and it'd be fun to say
well there's there's a there's like a
whole IQ thing where more women are in
the in the middle than in the right
either the greater male variance
hypothesis I think it's probably the
aggressive the aggressiveness is is you
know the risk-taking and stuff whereas
men are more uh more prone to take risk
well every time I have a friend that
I've gone to casinos with and every time
we've gone together like he takes big
risks and I take like no risks and he
makes a lot of money and I end up losing
80 or whatever and he's like oh you need
to take risks you know and I'm like oh
but it's my money
it's just longer so this I suck at it
this is uh this guy Dave said some risks
but he said quote that I'd ever do it
again but it sure caused a fuss and
created a buzz and a lot of extra prize
money for the ladies women are every bit
as good as men in any game that requires
mental skill and wits he is technically
technically correct and it's the greater
male variance hypothesis what do you
what what he's saying is if you were to
probably do if you probably were to
average it out you would find that the
average man and average woman are
probably comparable in general skill in
games like poker or chess the issue is
they are substantially more stupid men
who suck and competent men who are who
are who are good because there's greater
male variants so most women fall in the
middle and then I feel bad for women
because that means it means for for
women they are more likely to encounter
stupid men and smarter men yeah so it's
just frustrating across the board and
this is every time dealing with men as a
woman that's right well I'm sure a pain
in the end because most of them are
dumber than you yeah and then a lot of
them are smarter but they're a couple a
couple well it's actually a a bell curve
so you have I was talking about me
personally oh yeah for sure but I mean
like the the day-to-day interaction for
a woman working in an office is probably
going to be with the lower end of the
bell curve men and so women are probably
experiencing many more stupid men than
men experience of women yep well you
know you talk to these male feminists
and you try to explain this principle
them you say men are more likely to be
smart or dumb whereas women are more
likely to be average and they go I've
never noticed that women seem less
intelligent than me I have bad news
buddy
you are on that Spectrum right now
whenever
you're so much smarter than us I'm like
ooh it makes sense I already said male
feminists
at that lower end of the development but
I mean it makes sense that you know
dudes that are more aggressive and
actually that are smart guys they're
going to be the ones that are going to
go out and try to start something on
their own and I'm I'm sure
yeah absolutely yes but in an office
it's going to end up with the midwits
yes being an office is awful yeah so a
lot of these prominent feminist writers
are midwits and uh so for Frozen like
yeah like the women who work at Jezebel
and vice Oh you mean like Taylor Lorenz
and all of these they're midwives Media
Matters they are slightly above average
in intelligence and that means they're
going to be surrounded by a bunch of
really dumb men and then they're gonna
you know the perfect social support that
experience
yeah you got to understand this too the
the
I'm gonna swear but this is an actual
scientific term so I'm I'm warning
everybody this is the actual academic
phrase sneaky really that is not
an insult that is not a gag it's not a
joke it's a reference it's a little
insulting well it's a it's a reference
to in biology
in species you have the dominant men and
you have the dominant males and the
sneaky males and the sneaky
males will go in the middle of
the night in some species and then
reproduce under you know they'll sneak
in to reproduce while the dominant
strong man who is the authority is
unaware that's why they're called sneaky
male feminists are described
similarly in that they are men who will
say whatever they think the one wants to
hear in order to get access to
reproduction then you have the confident
you know I guess you know strong man
types who win or or through confidence
and Status are attractive to women so
you have the sneaky and then you
have the the kind of sneaky
though like they're they're very like
you can see that when you look at them
not when you're on birth control not not
when you're a male feminist not when you
no not not when you're a feminist and
you're surrounded by nothing but nothing
and surprise surprise it is no surprise
to me that these feminists are writing
articles being like all men are this way
because you've surrounded yourself with
nothing but low quality sneaky
men well and they always project that's
why those guys always go men just want
to use women's bodies you're telling me
about yourself
I'm pretty sure Michael Knowles who
married his high school sweetheart and
had a family was intending on more than
just having a body of this person for
decades exactly and you and I were
speaking about this on my podcast a
while ago Libby but what they project in
such egregious ways they say
conservatives just want to use women for
their bodies and only see them as
birthing people even though they use
phrases like birthing person and now
they're all they're advocating for
surrogacy where you literally just use a
woman for her body and see her as a baby
maker rather than a person you're
committed to yeah I think everyone knows
how I feel about seriously we've been
through that indeed
yeah it's it's a self it's it's a
I don't know how you correct for this
problem when liberal women surround
themselves with male feminists you
repeal the 19th I mean I don't think
that changes that women are going to be
surrounded by men who are going to say
whatever the women want to hear in order
to get access to banging them I
think misconception right about
relationships I I think when you fall in
love with your high school sweetheart
you should probably marry them
you should probably marry the person you
fall in love with and no wait that's not
what they're saying nowadays no nowadays
all these other things I saw this thing
on Instagram and it was like you're
gonna have three great loves in your
life and it went to list them and it was
like the first love right a horoscope
right no this was like it was on
Instagram I don't know it was the it was
the sneaky algorithm is what it
was okay like is this Instagram thing
he's like hey I'm number three right you
know that's the best one but it was like
it went through them all like all these
different things and it was like well
why not just
why not just get together with the
person what's in love with first what's
happening is that's not a feminist yeah
are working for these corporations like
Vice BuzzFeed Etc and they're surrounded
by sneaky men yes and again I'm
not saying I love your loophole it's not
a loophole it's an actual biological
term like biologist magical word
biologists describe this method of
reproduction as sneaky well I
appreciate it so what happens then when
these women are sitting around and
they're like what do you think about
sexual liberation of course the sneaky
are like yeah it's empowering
you should totally and Bang everybody
protest topless that'll show us in the
early days of the feminist movement the
feminists were not all gung-ho about
abortion it was men who got involved and
were like let's put abortion in
everyone's like I get a consequence free
sexual accidents I wanted to hook up I
don't want to have a family right so why
didn't you go it's like a dentist in um
uh uh it's always sunny it's always
sunny when he you know he supports the
pro-choice because he's like I don't
have a family are you crazy
I saw a lot of it when I was younger but
they that even even right now I'm
actually impressed with some of the
jokes they've been willing to do wait
are they still on yeah yeah
I guess they just did an episode with um
Brian Cranston and uh uh Aaron what's it
Aaron Paul probably the bad guy yeah
yeah both of them Let's uh let's jump to
this next story ladies and gentlemen
crack open your celebratory drinks we've
got breaking news from The New York
Times Vice is said to be headed for
bankruptcy the company which was once
valued at 5.7 billion has been
struggling to find a buyer this year in
fact the reporting it's going to go to
auction look at this Vice I got 50 bucks
I had to offer stands 50 bucks Vice
would continue operating normally and
run an auction to sell the company over
a 45-day period with Fortress Investment
Group in pole position as the most
likely acquirer
is
this is amazing that's it it's all
coming Crashing Down it is kind of sad I
got to tell you when I when I started at
Vice it was not as bad as it had become
in fact it was quite good
Shane Smith the CEO had gone on Colbert
and said look we're not Democrats or
Republicans we're storytellers we're
just trying to you know figure this
thing out and I'm like that's amazing
the videos they were producing were just
like uh your bar buddy telling you a
story about how he walked through this
place here's what he saw there was no
pretense there was no Authority and then
as soon as they got money he said bring
in the pretense bringing the authority
and bring in the feminists and it burned
the company to the ground I gotta be
honest when Vice was sex drugs and rock
and roll and edgy it was skyrocketing it
was and the moment they decided to get
woke they went
yeah well it's like what Elon Musk was
saying about the woke mind virus you
know and it took over Vice and it
destroyed it took over BuzzFeed there's
nothing and it's basically like that's
the reason post-millennial exists
there's literally massive kind of stuff
yeah there's nothing cool about woke
right like it's cool to be nice to
people and and that's what you you know
you want to treat people with respect
and stuff I get it but there's nothing
edgy there's nothing cool about being
woke and vice's whole Foundation was
built on being edgy and cool they snuck
into North Korea like the whole point
was because they were falling like their
New York 30s were always sexy and really
fun well I mean I never went but it was
uh you know it's like it's supposed to
be edgy and cool and then it it's like
all woke is is just like society's Hall
monitors and it sucks because all they
ever do is you can't say this can't do
that blah blah blah blah and it's
totally antithetical to what Vice
started out as it was supposed to be the
CNN of the street it was supposed to be
anti-establishment it was edgy it was
taking over and then as soon as they got
any semblance of of money
immediately Joe Biden's coming in for an
interview back the Obama Administration
we're gonna get oh we're so excited for
this
they went full and just as soon as the
government came a knocking as soon as
the investor came to knock and they said
we will do anything you say and this was
inevitable yep now I'm sure they're
going to come out try and give you all
the reasons about well it's changing
landscape and media no I disagree
there's a reason why Tim Cass is
expanding and vice is imploding and
BuzzFeed is imploding and there's a
reason why all these journalists are
just so salty I offer them jobs every
time do you really absolutely absolutely
but you know has anyone taken you up on
it uh there actually are people advice
who are good people who are just
documentary filmmakers who are like let
me know if you ever need a pitch because
you know we've always want to go and
travel and do some stuff
that's a nonprofit well the people there
who are good are the people there at
Vice who are good are going to find jobs
making things that are good instead of
that garbage and the people there who
suck and are dragging the company down
are gonna either change or they're not
gonna find work so that's the thing it's
creative destruction
I can't believe it's fine it it really
is sad I mean I looked at the old Vice
building for sale 34 million dollars oh
wow it's a compound in Williamsburg in
New York it's got a whole bunch of
business in it but man I I went and
looked at it since Vice moved to a new
building in South uh you know the
southern part of Williamsburg in New
York and uh the old buildings just
Fallen apart it's like nothing it's like
graffiti all over it I think a large
portion of it was actually torn down
yeah and it is I'm like man I'm looking
at the picture and I'm like I used to
stand out in front of there you know
just talking smack with other employees
all these stories talking news talking
politics finance and uh now it's all
just falling apart yeah and it's crazy
because I'm just thinking back to 20
2012 2013 when I'm like 2012 I'm talking
to these guys 2013 I'm getting hired
over there and they would not listen
but you know what
part of me I wonder is if Shane Smith
cares I think he does because brand was
always so important to him it was always
the most important thing to build up the
brand and I think he want advice to
become Disney to become CNN to be this
Legacy brand and because of his
inability to see what was happening
around him and his embracing of this
crackpot cult garbage he burned his own
name to the ground and now what does he
have to show for it well look he may
still be worth a lot of money but most
of his wealth was tied up in Vice so
when people said that he was a
billionaire it was only because of
vice's value at 5.7 billion he cashed
out I think like like 30 or 40 million
dollars maybe and now that Vice is
worthless and entering bankruptcy to be
sold I don't know how much I'll even get
out of this I think it is I think it is
too bad I always really liked their
photography and you know the like
edgy nature of it I thought it was fun
but though but those people who were
good at doing that they're gonna find
work they've got organizations that are
decent yeah exactly because they want to
start something new themselves exactly
because with it with an organization
like this and this is part of why I'm
cheering it on it's not because I'm glad
that the people who are talented and
hard-working and dedicated are out of
work it's because all of those people
were locked into an organization with a
bunch of idiots who were woke and had no
idea how to direct the company and now
the workers who are genuinely good are
free to pursue opportunities at
companies that will guide them better
and lead them better or like you said
start their own businesses and I think
that's a beautiful thing yeah I think
it's always good to start your own
Enterprise one thing I mean at post
millennial I came on in 2019 as a
freelancer and now I'm like you know
your top dog part of running the company
and like I heard of you know I'm part of
running the company I don't don't try to
avoid accountability here all right
anyway but the uh the fun thing about it
and like a big part of the reason I
wouldn't want to go somewhere else is
like I've been working on it this whole
time I've been like making it with these
people that you know I really enjoy that
that work there and it's like we built
this thing why would we you know I would
never want to do something else like my
hands are stuck in the muck of this
project this may be one of the biggest
get woke go brokes we have ever seen
yeah pulled up a story from 2017 Vice
media's Shane Smith is now a billionaire
they said that due to a uh due to a
foreign 450 million dollar investment
round Shane Smith's Holdings were now
worth some 1 billion dollars they say
that he had roughly 20 percent of Vice
after applying a 10 private company
discount to its valuation and adding
Smith's spread of some 33 million
dollars in real estate his net worth
totals an estimated 1 billion if he had
20 of the company and that's what put
him at a billion dollars with Vice
currently going bankrupt his net worth
is now in the low tens of millions ah
he's broke he went I looked down on him
he has nothing tens of millions no no no
hold on he's he's got more money than he
could ever spend I'm sure he even said
he says in this he says I don't give an
issue about money I've got more money
I'm worth more money than I can ever
spend that's absolutely absolutely true
so he's going to be able to retire very
very comfortably and probably be
independently wealthy for the rest of
his life he never has to work again but
going from being a billionaire running
one of the most valuable media companies
to losing all of that in a matter of a
few years all because they wanted to get
well and you know what they want to make
any excuse they can and I can prove
outright or I'll just say outright it is
BS Vice had no reason to lose its
standing it was the wokeness it is
divisive it splits your audience and
they hyper polarized they they basically
told everybody who ever liked Vice to f
off let me tell you a story about when I
was talking to one of my producer
buddies that I've known from Vice for a
long time Vice ran an article and it
said this horrible app can show you what
women look like topless and it said
someone developed it okay I remember
this developed an AI app that if it
takes a picture of a woman you can press
render and it will AI remove their top
and I said do you know what vice's
headline would have been in 2013 this
amazing app can show you any because
they were mocking they were trying to be
edgy and be like screw you can do it
everyone and they decided to get woke
and be Hall Monitor feminists and they
basically told their entire audience you
are bad people F off and I was told by
this dude advice well but we have to
change we can't do that anymore and I'm
like then you're gonna fail because
you're not going to be Vice
trans Vice I think it's fair to say that
sucks though I think it's fair to say
that particular app sucks but the point
was it's not that vice's old headline
would literally be intending to talk
about how great it is the app exists it
was meant to insult the established
narrative and be edgy and say screw your
system but but instead they became Hall
monitors I mean I gotta be honest they
probably wouldn't have even written the
article they'd be like who cares let's
complain about how screwed up everything
is and tell everyone to go f themself
sex drugs and rock and roll instead they
were like let's put on our our button-up
shirts and then go complain about how
oppressive these people are
all they did was start pwning up to the
establishment narrative and people don't
care for that especially young people
but more importantly this is what Bud
Light did Vice went to their readers and
said now that we have investment we
don't care about you and we're going to
Target a different demographic and guess
what the younger demographic did not
care they did not care for the hall
monitor style of of content so they
don't like it I mean because because
what all of these wokie people and the
corporations don't realize is that they
are now the establishment and the kids
are coming up and they're looking at it
and they're going stop telling us what
to do stop telling us what to believe we
don't subscribe to your whole world view
we're going to bucket we're going to get
off this whole train and so that's what
they're doing like you know my son and
his friends they look at this stuff and
they see right through it they see that
it's total ideological garbage and they
want to make their own way they want to
come up with their own opinions and
ideas I have two teenage nephews and
they're the same yeah and I have mad
respect for these kids looking at being
like you are the establishment and the
Millennials didn't realize that when
they were buying into this whole
narrative it was the establishment
narrative you know and gen z i I think
we're still waiting to see what happens
with them but you know they're all these
this guy Sykes with the tampon guy and
all this stuff that's what they're doing
and they're getting all this money from
the Biden Administration now to to be
influencers as tend to start you know
spilling this garbage narrative oh yeah
did you see those uh those two uh
Twitter guys the Gen Z
what's his name you know talking about
the two gen Z dudes who are making
videos where they're all smarmy and like
we don't like the Republicans they we're
not paid by the DNC and there's a
community not being like they're they're
they're hired by a management firm
that's funded by the DNC they're getting
communities the greatest trick The
Establishment ever pulled was convincing
people that it wasn't the establishment
that was really clever Obama did that
yeah he did an amazing job and I gotta
say we're counter-cultural because they
liked the president which is absurd I
when I was a teenager I found it very
patronizing when I would
have The Misfortune of seeing anything
on MTV because someone else was watching
it I would cringe because it always felt
very how do you do fellow kids and I
knew that these were adults writing he's
fantastic but I it was obvious that
these were adults writing young people
saying the things that these weird
creepy adults thought young people
should be saying so that I would watch
that and go that's so
that's so it made me extremely angry as
a youth and unfortunately now they have
this edge of being able to promote
whichever voice they want through the
algorithm on Tick Tock because sure
you're always going to find young people
who are mixed up and will repeat these
talking points and because it's not as
highly produced because it's not clearly
coming from Hollywood right or the
establishment young people yes it seems
organic and it seems like something the
majority of young people actually
believe because it's continually
recommended by the algorithm and it's
possible that among that generation
that's true but regardless my point is
the propaganda catches on more easily
when it's your fellow young people
saying it and it's promoted as opposed
to a highly produced television show
that I know is being written by people
in their 40s right it's it's very
produced it's extremely uh it's it's
it's very much the algorithm pushing
pushing the ideas that that I don't
think that are actually popular with
people like I don't like proof but yeah
I don't think that I think that it's uh
Shadow and zero hips Bust or butt are
evidence that none of this stuff is but
I mean with young people that I mean
yeah I think they reject it and I think
that that's what we do anything too the
more we see like I was writing about
this recently I've been giving a lot of
thought the uh the current beauty
standards are more unhealthy and
unattainable than the previous ones
they're the rejection abuse are we
supposed to look like Elliott page and
get our boobs off are we supposed to
look like lizzo and gain I don't know
like a lot of weight it's a rejection
she's obviously very beautiful like
she's a she's a woman but I heard I
heard Jared Leto in her face she's was
trying to gain weight for a roll so he
would take a pint of Ben and Jerry's
every night microwave it and then pour
olive oil and soy sauce and start up and
then chug it crazy
ice cream he gained weight so fast that
he couldn't stand and he had a
wheelchair
helps absorb the water I guess and I
remember very distinctly I used to eat a
pint of ice cream every day when I was
in college
I was stoned
but I realized very at a certain point I
was like wait I'm gaining weight I
really and I switched to a half pint and
I stopped getting dude I one thing I saw
in college that's College I'm I'm
finding a lot of people that uh I've
known and a lot of personalities that I
used to you know watch when I was going
to pro skateboarders musicians are
becoming more conservative and they had
no like I think there's a rejection of
what the left is doing to the point
where you've got edgy Urban liberal
types who are just like y'all have lost
your minds and now they're like people
need to have families and and get jobs
and they used to be the sex drugs and
rock and roll people and they're just
like none of this is okay it's it's gone
too far the
degeneracy is literally destroying
companies I'm not going to name anyone
specifically but there are some famous
skateboarders and musicians who are very
much from the world of sex drugs and
rock and roll who are now like have a
family buy property work hard save for
the future and I think it's because
they're they're looking into the mirror
that is the left and being like nah
it up over here too I know guys like you
know I'm I'm perfectly happy to be
liberal a bit libertine but I don't
think that that should be the social
ethos yeah well like this is one band
All That Remains yeah
very often you know it's normal that as
people get older they do tend to become
more conservative part of what's so
Insidious now is that people on the left
are encouraging these young people to
receive body mutilating surgeries that
they will not be able to reverse and
part of what ends up happening as a
result of that is a person is so bought
into it that they can never admit it was
wrong
among other men horrible yeah well let's
utilize your body how do you come back
from that well that's psychologically
let's jump to the story because we do
have big news kiss co-founder Paul
Stanley 71 slams parents who confuse
their children about gender identity
branding child sex changes a sad and
dangerous fad this is the front man this
is the guy the star on his face for kiss
yeah this is the guy star child star
child it doesn't even look bad he's 71
isn't that crazy yeah he doesn't look
bad and uh he's aged better than me look
at that does he have here we go he said
as uh I'll read some of what he says
there's a big difference between
teaching acceptance and normalizing and
even encouraging participation in a
lifestyle that confuses young children
into questioning their sexual
identification as though some sort of
gain and then parents in some cases
allow it he says there are individuals
who as adults may decide reassignment as
their needed choice but turning this
into a game or parents normalizing it as
some sort of natural alternative or
believing that because a little boy
likes to play just in his sister's
clothes or a girl and her brothers we
should lead them steps further down a
path that's far from the innocence of
what they're doing
I I think uh uh I think he's completely
right you know kids will will play with
whatever toys because they're just kids
they're exploring the world and what's
happening now is this is the meme it's a
kid playing with a doll and then the
parent says I'll prep the surgery right
it's like oh we play with the doll well
there it is the funny thing is and I've
pointed this out so as many other many
others how is it that they argue
simultaneously that gender is a social
construct meaning playing with dolls is
not unique to males or females but then
if a male or if a male plays with dolls
or a female with a football that proves
they're actually identifying as the
opposite sex the weird thing too is uh
the genderization of toys and clothes
came I came like after my childhood
after my brother's childhood and you
started to go into the Lego section and
you would see girls LEGOs and boys Legos
that didn't used to be the thing when I
would hang out and my friend Nikki's
basement and play with her brother's
Legos we just we just all played Legos
it wasn't a big deal and the same thing
with the Barbie dolls like we would just
all play it wasn't a big deal no I
joined I joined a girls Lego competition
and I just crushed I crushed I joined a
girls Barbie competition even and I
still beat them it was incredible
I would just like to say like I would
kick your ass in Barbies in all
seriousness there was a clip I saw from
your show and I can't remember the
guests and if you can please shout him
out but he was saying there were studies
on how boys and girls will play
differently they'll play with the same
toy yeah but when the boy picks up the
toy he starts embodying the character
he's playing with whereas when the girl
picks up the toy she has the character
act the way she does so even when we're
playing with her as kids playing with
different toys we we urge to the same
yeah
the way he described it I feel bad that
I can't remember who it was but the way
he described it is when a boy picks up a
Batman toy now he's Batman he's like I'm
Batman he's just playing like Batman
when the girl picks Batman up Batman's
like do you want to have a tea party
then Batman wants a teapot exactly like
Batman actually play Barbies with my
friends at my mom's apartment and uh
like the neighbors and stuff we had this
Barbie Barbie Dreamhouse dream house and
my friend Julia's brother came to play
with us and he was older he was like 12
I want to say and we were like 10 or
something but he took one of my Barbies
that was disabled and strapped together
with them rubber bands and he was like
this this is the Madam of the Barbie
dream house and we were like what's that
oh my God
television and its consequences have
been a disaster for the human race
we had the Barbie brothel we had like oh
my whole thing set up it was ridiculous
and I told my mom about it I was like oh
Mark said this and that and my mom was
like I can't go over there anymore
it was Ethan van scriver it was said
that Ethan van scriver with the uh the
um comic yeah artists awesome yeah
someone mentioned in the chat so I I
wouldn't know because I've never been
female but when I used to play with Lego
was you're right when I would play with
toys
me and my friends would take the action
figures or whatever and we would voice
them we would be like I am going to take
over the world like we were the
character was was us we were like acting
as them that's what we used to do with
the Barbies we'd like well that's the
opposite of what you're saying yeah
what I was told we would do like stories
we would like invent whole worlds with
the Barbies and mostly they ended up
having sex the issue is when you would
play with Barbie was the Barbie
channeling you and you were like I'm
Barbie and Barbie would do things so
Barbie was another character I just like
the character of the you know see I
distinctly remember when I was like we
do the voices would be like I'm going
over here now yeah when I was a kid like
if I was playing with like GI Joes or
whatever and my like cousins were
playing with Barbie or whatever and they
wanted to like have the Barbies and the
GI Joes interact I would get upset
because they would want the GI Joes to
do like Barbie things and I'm like no GI
Joes don't do that yeah yeah they're
going to fight and and they would be
like no that's why my cousin would be
like he had the Hulk Hogan and the Rowdy
Roddy Piper guys and so whenever I
played Barbies with him it was like
wrestling Barbie yes would they have
like the GI Joes at the mall with the
Barbies and then one gym
the other and he goes hey that uniform
what what uh platoon were you with it
was stolen valor Disco
I don't I don't think Stolen Valor was
really a thing back then to be honest
I'm sure it was they just got away with
it because no one was filming it
yeah D Snyder came out on Twitter and
actually agreed with Paul Stanley and so
I'm feeling I'm feeling pretty confident
and I'm feeling pretty white pilled as
of lately because I think I think what's
happening is that we are reaching well
critical mass I think Bud Light is very
very important in more ways than people
realize the fact that Bud Light sales
are down 21.4 percent suggests to
regular people who are the people who
are like I don't know what's right or
wrong I just want to be on the right
side of History are now going maybe it's
not the woke people yep if Rock Stars
celebrities and the average person is
not buying this beer anymore so now
imagine this Bud Light is uncool nobody
wants to buy it now you're going to see
that rejection of this because a regular
person who normally just follows the
trends it's gonna be like I I don't I
don't drink Bud Light whatever you say
guys and then a beer company is going to
hire an actual woman to advertise their
beer it used to be that the joke was uh
the joke Family Guy no don't do that
they're really kind of revolutionary say
that uh drink our beer and beautiful
women will want to have sex with you and
the commercial was women that was that
was the commercial
and now the commercial is if you drink
Bud Light you are sexually attracted to
people of the same sex as you and I
don't think your average guy who's going
to a barbecue wants to convey that
message to his neighbors so they're just
like that's not my I don't drink that
stuff don't look at me Bud Light it's
reverse conversion therapy
cut your wiener off the hole I mean they
used to sell sex for everything I think
they're um when it comes to a lot of
alcoholic drinks like Bacardi Silver or
o or whatever I don't know if they still
have those but like Fruity light drinks
and wine coolers or whatever are seen as
effeminate and guys want to drink like
Guinness like a strong dark beer or
something so now you have Bud Light
being like the frilliest of Fufu Brands
exactly and outright stating like yeah
like white Claw is more masculine if
they were right yep if they were selling
like strawberry daiquiris I could
understand
yeah but now you have a beer that is
widely seen as effeminate and surprise
surprise to all of the woke gen's ears
or whatever guys don't want to be seen
as weak and to be fair drinks beer like
dudes drink beer women buy those fruity
things those like Bud Lights are the
beer that you get for like the hour or
where the beer that like you get for the
afternoon because you didn't want to
have like too heavy beer and it's kind
of thirst quenching and stuff and then
you drink the heavier stuff later it's
nobody's doing that anymore no one's
drinking that it's the beer that you buy
because you're not only manly enough to
drink beer you're manly enough to not
care if anyone you're with wants good
beer so you bring that over that's the
demographic they're like Dylan Mulvaney
that's who will slap up shut up and
drink it is pretty masculine right my
main point with with bringing the
subject uh back up is
regular people the left is trying to win
the culture War by saying you are on the
wrong side of history and because civil
rights is the right side of History they
are trying to pretend that they
represent civil rights when in fact they
represent segregation and fashion and
fascism
ideologies but they're wearing a mask of
civil rights now that regular people
though are saying no to Bud Light
many people who are following the walk
are going to question whether or not
that's the safe place to be because they
were just going along with the crowd hey
the crowd's not there man the crowd's
clearly boycotting Bud Light what ended
up happening to gillette's numbers after
that out I think is there a men's brand
they were a men's brand and I remember
people saying go woke get broke or get
woke go broke I'll tell you what happens
when Hershey's had a male sponsor their
women's candy bar that Canadian we got
that crazy delicious is she her candy
bar by Jeremy's chocolates isn't it and
I will stress they don't pay me to do
this no they do not dude people and it's
funny because whenever anyone responds I
know but I feel weird chewing into the
microwave I'll just push the microphone
unbelievable I'll just chew over here I
was there you go uh whenever these
boycotts happen people go oh absolutely
why do you care so much I don't know
because it's being forced onto me at all
times by everyone because we're
literally a year away from s the D bigot
no dude that was like two years ago well
I mean yeah that that was the joke two
years ago I really do it's getting to
the point where there are people that do
me and not that there's a lot of people
that support the argument there are
people that do make the art the argument
that if you won't date a trans woman if
you're a straight man and you won't date
a trans women you're a bigot and I don't
give a I'm a bigot I don't care if
you know who really gets pushed that has
this pushed on them as are lesbians yeah
yeah lesbians are like wait I'm not
doing the right thing what am I supposed
to do let me do the right thing I'll
I'll do the thing and so yeah lesbians
are easy to push around it turns out you
know the crazy thing is like a lot of
women I was I was right before that in
Iran if you're a gay man they force you
get a sex change and if you're a gay
woman the same thing yeah but now what
we're seeing is these young women who
are like autistic and gay are being told
they're trans and should get you know
sex changes or whatever mastectomies and
that's like weirdly similar to what Iran
does it's very similar to what Iran does
and it was like what like 4000 400
percent increase in young women deciding
to be trans so this was interesting so
you have all these young women deciding
to be trans seeing more chocolate you
have all these young women deciding to
be trans right around puberty and they
look at like the you know they look at
like Womanhood and they're like I don't
want any piece of that that seems awful
you've got like the tampons you've got
the whole thing it's awful there's
nothing it's hard to see anything good
about it right and so they decide that
they want to be boys instead and they go
through that whole thing I was recently
seeing I think it was um a writer who
does a lot of trans writing and stuff is
basically hitting menopause like
pre-menopause and being like I am trans
masculine now and it's kind of this as
it's the reverse of kind of the same
thing you're look she's looking at Crone
Hood she's looking at being an old woman
no one wants to be an old woman even
more than no one wants to be a grown-up
woman you'll get this everything in your
body just like sags down it's terrible
it's horrible nobody wants any part of
that and so now she's going to be
masculine she's getting a breast binder
and it's like yeah because they're
already like hanging down to your navel
probably you know it's not like just
so no it's like the same kind of thing
like when a woman hits a change of life
whatever that change of life is she's
like I don't want any part of that
um and who can blame her it sucks well
also no I think that's a very good point
I mean girls are generally uncomfortable
during puberty there are a lot of
changes there and especially when you
look at the current cultural Paradigm
women are told not to want to do things
that are natural to women and also one
aspect of this people don't talk about
is that the average age of first
exposure to pornography is 13 years old
and there is really gross horrible
hardcore stuff out there and you can
absolutely imagine a girl encountering
that going oh my gosh that's what sex is
that's what happens to women no I don't
want to be a woman someone someone super
chatted that we should look at Noodles
the guitar player from the offspring's
reaction to uh kiss and I just want to
say this I know this is a bit personal
for me to say but this may be one of the
greatest days of my life
the guitar the guitarist from The
Offspring has me blocked the very first
song I ever learned how to play in the
guitar was the kids aren't all right
written by this man and he has blocked
me on Twitter truly a day for me to
behold is your cover that bad uh he's uh
he probably blocked me because you know
I'm friends and play music with their
old drummer who they crapped all over
because they're nasty evil people mm-hmm
and uh man you know what I will say one
thing that frustrates me
is that there's a lot of secrets about
celebrities that if people only knew but
this guy from my understanding is lying
about everything really
I can't say much more it's not my place
to say and that bothers me but until
someone comes out and comes on the
record about the band and about their
actual uh um let's just say about the
truth there's not much more I can say
but what I will say is this many of
these people in Hollywood who post these
tweets do so just because they want to
get the pr brownie points and they voted
for Trump
oh and they voted for Trump for one
reason taxes taxes that's it they don't
care about anything yeah these people
that's why a lot of rappers will vote
for Trump because they're like into the
not having to pay us here's what all the
rappers voted I don't believe any
rappers voted for Joe Biden I don't care
what they say publicly none of them
voted they're all like I'm voting for
Trump let me let me let me show you an
old creepy man let me let me show you
what noodles actually said I clicked his
Twitter account to see his response to
Paul Stanley and saw that I was blocked
he said this very disappointing take
especially from someone who wore high
heels makeup and teased up hair his
whole career as a young kid your band
helped teach me that I could be whatever
I wanted to be I guess it was just
gimmickery after all Ben Collins of NBC
says the idea of Kiss of all bands
complaining about gender non-conforming
people is just chef's kiss the funny
thing is he is of all the people to come
out and say kids should not be doing
this he is the perfect person in that he
wore high heels and makeup and he never
cut off his genitals he never did one
time
[Applause]
children may dress in their brothers and
sisters clothes and that's just
something they want to do don't tell
them to to get surgeries and drugs and
they're coming on being like yeah but
you wore those clothes he said it's okay
that kids do you can't wear the clothes
it's so like that's the thing about drag
that drives me crazy too is you have all
this like drag for kids and it's like
guys drag is an adult thing we all had a
great time at the drag show why why are
we suddenly imagining that a bunch of
guys who dress up like campy women like
like fake beauty pageant women and have
uh taken on entertainment stage names
that are like sexual names for the most
part why are we imagining that these are
the people who should be entertaining
and educating our kids it doesn't make
any sense
like go to the drag show have a great
time get trashed enjoy yourself listen
I'm a little bit of a libertine here and
there so but like I never had an issue
with that I've been to plenty of drag
shows you know I've had friends who do
drag but uh don't go hang out at my kids
Library doing drugs it's not surgery
yeah and don't go reading them books
about how they should cut their dicks
off yeah well I think Matt Walsh said it
very well when he described drag as
burlesque for gay men sure that's
basically what it is rolling a bunch of
hacks too yeah
[Laughter]
just I haven't heard that phrase it's
been a while I know it's great it's been
a while but I mean you're I think it's
probably not politically correct anymore
to say that nothing's politically
correct anything as soon as you open
your mouth you're gonna get cancer where
else it doesn't matter I mean you showed
up here at the castle you were you're
over it's done
um I I think that I think that the it's
obvious it should be obvious and I
really think that the average person
when they hear what goes on when it
comes to like surgeries and stuff
they're like that's not right that's not
that is so far outside of how we treat
any other issue that anyone has ever
like you don't cut up healthy bodies
because of psychological issues whether
it be AGP or whether it be
um dysmorphia or whatever you want to
call it right like I don't believe the
wrong body thing because I'm not a guy
that believes in a soul I think your
brain is your brain you're not born with
a man's brain in a woman's body you're
born with a woman's brain in a woman's
body or a man's brain in a man's body
because your brain is part of your body
that's it
um that's a physicalist approach yeah I
mean that's and that's how I I mean I'm
not a spiritual guy I'm you know that's
that's just my thing but also gender
isn't the soul like even if you are
spiritual gender is not the same well
yeah yeah and it turned but that's weird
it's it becomes that whole creepy weird
religion thing that the life has got
going on yes well it's a cult because
there's no forgiveness I would say just
have forgiveness and I I would add this
in there as well I I do believe in a
soul but also I believe human beings are
a body Soul composite and you are both
it's not like you're a body and you have
a solar you're a soul and you have a
body you are your body and your soul the
idea that you are something different
from your body is a contradiction it
doesn't make sense right
yeah
don't cut your wiener off yeah please
please yeah that was an excellent
response to the spiritual uh yeah I mean
no he's summer he summarized it put it
in layman's terms and I think there is
something you know I think there is a
spiritualness to having a sexual life
you know so I think it's just really a
crime too to destroy these children's
bodies before they have a chance to be
involved in loving relationships 100 the
the fact that that there are so many
people that Advocate to do things
pre-puberty so because allegedly it
makes it it makes it easier to
transition which I don't believe because
there's the stories of jazz Jennings
like how her body yeah yeah it's a train
wreck because
so anyways my point being like I I can't
see how and I keep coming back to the
same same point I can't see how
endorsing a surgery on children people
you know people that haven't their
brains haven't even fully developed go
by what the insurance companies say the
insurance companies know you can't you
know you know what when I was 25 to rent
a car like that's it when I was 12 years
old I knew that I really wanted to do
drugs like I was very clear on that I
was like oh that's interesting I
definitely want to do drugs and I
thought okay you're 12. so maybe just
like hold off
and I made a deal with myself I was like
okay you got to hold off until you're
18. and then you can try that's the most
mature thing I've ever heard a 12 year
old do I didn't think about drugs until
I was 15 and someone said you want to
smoke a joint I said yep well that way
well that way when somebody was 50 when
I was 15 and someone was like do you
want to smoke a joint I was like no I
gotta wait I actually had someone offer
me cocaine when I was 16 and I had
really wanted to do cocaine when I was
12. this was like one of the drugs
now I'll tell you the story another time
it's for the the after show definitely
an after show story all right yeah
anyways
um but yeah so someone offered me
cocaine when I was 16 and I was like you
know what I I have to wait until I'm 18.
all the drugs like LSD all the stuff I
was like I gotta I'm waiting on that
so I think when you're 12 you you have a
way to know like hey maybe I shouldn't
cut my boots off
spaz shocking I was a alienated bullied
weirdo but I I knew some stuff yeah I
mean shockingly people don't know what's
best for them when they're younger I
remember a few years ago I was at a bar
with one of my cousins and we must have
been in our early 20s and the bartender
there was a bit older she was I believe
in her 50s and my cousin said something
like I'm never gonna have kids the
bartender goes how old are you and she
says I'm 22. partner's like shut up
you you're 22 years old okay you're not
gonna sit here and tell me that you're
never gonna have kids because you don't
want to have them right now you're going
to get older and you're probably gonna
want them I had that experience when I
was 22. I didn't want to have kids I
think well I think many women in this
culture do and I'm not saying that
that's historically normal but in this
culture it's certainly normal in your
early 20s to not want kids and it
doesn't mean that you're never going to
want them later yeah yeah historically I
think it's it probably was odd
historically very abnormal yeah I
actually thinks I'm not kidding I heard
that spinster was defined as unmarried
by 22. I need to double check on that
but I was born when my mom was 26 and I
remember that being like she's old
I was my mom I think my mom was 22 when
I was born okay so in the 17th century a
woman was considered an old maid if she
remained unmarried and childless by the
time she reached her mid-20s wow today
the word spinster is more commonplace
and is used to refer to women between
the ages of 23 and 26. I've never heard
it used to refer to women between 23 and
26 but probably because I live in the
west I bet you in other countries it's
more shocking to them probably yeah
could be
have we solved all of life's problems
yeah we fixed it we got really close
yeah I found out I found out that I'm an
old spinster today yeah you're in your
20s yes good for you
clock's ticking though I've almost I've
almost run out of 20s oh
don't worry you'll be fine your 30s are
gonna be great you know what yeah I
appreciate the optimism I don't know
with all the banks collapsing and stuff
I don't know
that's the thing like people have always
enjoyed youth but there was a time when
gaining age was seen as gaining
experience and therefore wisdom I can't
remember who the ancient philosopher was
who said it but no wise man ever wished
to be younger yeah my son was telling me
recently he's afraid to grow up and I
was like you're gonna be an awesome
adult you're gonna be great you're gonna
get to do whatever you want you're gonna
be responsible it's gonna be terrific
and he was like uh and I was like no for
real it's gonna be really good yeah well
it's it's natural for people to prefer
youth or want to be young but on top of
that our culture puts extra emphasis on
it
we have a very disordered valuation of
of Youth we we place it on far too high
a pedestal I think that's true too
that's probably accurate I I've always
viewed youth midlife and aging as a
human experience that people are
supposed to uh supposed to experience
yeah so like I when I was younger and
I'm seeing all these these like women or
they want to act like they're what I was
told is women always want to be 24. when
they're younger they want to dress like
they're older when they're older when
they want they want to put a makeup and
look like they're younger and I was kind
of like doesn't everybody go through
life where you have these things to
experience you get old it's part of it
it's a part of life I mean I guess if we
invent cures and immortality and stuff
people will just be satisfied with being
young forever but for the time being
it's kind of like yeah we're all gonna
get old you know enjoy it you get to
experience it something you will feel
and you will you will learn from and you
will see and you will uh you will
remember I just want and you'll die I
just want people to know that in chat
Luke said I'm 45 and now people are
saying I'm 45 in potato years
I guess that also works we got multiple
people 28 yeah 28 is 45 in potato years
what's the math on that I mean I have no
idea I'm not old enough to be good at
math yet I don't think I have Royal they
say IQ Peaks at like 22 so let's just
scroll down here as the old guy at the
table just the only thing that I have to
say about about getting older is like
just keep your body in good shape by
like exercising because like I don't
wanna I'm pushing I'm pushing 50 and I
have like I go to the gym and I don't
have any of the aches and pains that I
hear other people my age talk about the
exact same age Phil I don't know okay we
we might be we can compare it but you
won't just say how old you are well I'm
wealthier I'm not worried about it but
ladies you know okay I'm 48 yeah no
she's the one who brought it up but only
a little I'm 47. yes and I just turned
48 like a couple weeks ago okay Luke
just said I fart dust excuse me I don't
have to please continue
um but yeah like the the thing is like
you if you stay you have to stay active
and you have to just don't lose don't
don't gain a bunch of weight because
you're gonna be miserable whoa whoa
oh buddy I hear that I hear some body
non-positivity coming from over there
yes I don't appreciate it you're
overweight you have a negative body just
make sure when you're eating your she
her Jeremy's nutless chocolate bar you
restrict yourself because 21 grams of
sugar per bar
only four ingredients in soy free again
they don't pay me to do that
I guess my point is uh I cut out sugars
today you know I had you know what I had
today I had we we went to there's a
market in Potomac Maryland and they have
sushi grade salmon oh so we just bought
a big piece of salmon and we just cut it
and ate it raw yeah with avocado that
sounds perfect yeah I made some spicy
mayo it was like you know being a sushi
chef yeah that's a really good healthy
that's a really good dish very healthy
and for for uh and to drink I had this
uh delicious rise with Roberto so
actually the Roberto Jr uh this we just
got ours
so for people who are ordering it
they're gonna start seeing it already
but uh it came in the mail and I meet it
was like we got a brew some we gotta we
gotta Brew some of course we've had it
because we we are the ones who like took
all the samples and Blended everything
and then made it but we're really
excited to get it but yeah eating
healthy I want to get some of the whole
bean kind because I like to grind it
yourself I do yeah it's fresher and
better yeah we have those too so it's
fun it's sort of fun it's very fun
no but what I'm saying is uh take care
of yourself live your best life
you know be healthy exercise if you're
gonna be a exercise is so important it's
so important for your mental health it's
so important for your body like I'm I
can't stress enough go out but people
exercise until I was 30. people who
don't exercise don't understand when
you're sedentary the the like you might
feel like this is Baseline this is what
normal feels like ah man that if that's
the case when you start exercising
consistently you feel good all the time
it's so annoying too because I'll be in
a really bad mood and I'll realize I
haven't exercised and I'll be like damn
it now I have to go exercise and then I
feel better and then I'm annoyed it's
annoying that you're feeling you're like
man I don't know if you guys are aware
of this but telling people that they're
actually capable of making a difference
in their life by making better choices
is horrible and unfair and cruel and
marginalizing yeah you're right we're
not affirming people's poor choices
exactly I
more Angry than saying hey if you're
depressed like you should try getting a
better sleep schedule getting a better
diet exercising like oh
and you're like oh are you already doing
those things they're like no you should
do that again oh
there there you like it it's funny you
like that the second time thank you
that's how I'm going to express myself
more often disappointed
but that's literally that's literally
what they do that's literally what they
do when it's a crazy day they get upset
it's a weird dangle crazy day and I told
that bank to invest better and they're
like oh we're crashing I was like maybe
invest better and don't buy Bad Assets
and give out stupid loans and they went
I don't have the energy for it I kind of
just feel like
with that news of the bank collapse
people are just sitting around shrugging
being like we know but whatever
and then also you have Congress is going
to have to vote to raise the debt
ceiling that's a mess
that doesn't none of that seems it
doesn't seem good too
good to not do it we're all burned out
on all of it just like we know the
system has imploded and there's no need
to just say it at this point buy some
chickens and is sometimes the news day
is like that so I wake up every morning
I scan all the headlines I look at all
the newspapers you know I start thinking
about what we should cover and then you
realize I should buy chickens and
actually I had there's chickens next
door to me where I live and um this
morning I kept hearing the rooster and I
was like why am I still hearing this
rooster and then I looked outside all
the chickens had escaped they were all
running over my yard and I was like wait
a minute do I can I just go get one like
what do I do now they just let him go
and then I was uh driving over here
there were chickens like hanging out in
front of my car yeah don't you drive you
drive around in West Virginia and you'll
see chickens just walking around yeah
they go do their thing and they go home
they're like the cats same thing in
Hawaii really with chickens on Oahu yeah
like you're all over the place
it's really fun when I ride my I got my
electric motorcycle and I ride it up
here in the morning to come to work and
I can see chicken City and there's just
some doofy looking chicken just staring
at me and I'm just like isn't life great
well I come over here and they're all
like talking to me and I'm like hey
fellas what's going on yelling about
something or other we got little Luke in
the uh the Polish one he sounds just
like his dad he's got parted hair he's
blonde a big nose he's polish and he
yells a lot oh cool that sounds like a
pretty interesting chicken we should go
to super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because oh boy do we got a
members only uncensored show for you
tonight not family friendly so you've
been warned DeSantis
I'm gonna be vague with a he's just
signed uh into a fact
um a very extreme form of punishment for
a certain kind of criminal and uh not
very family friendly so we'll talk about
that over at timcast.com should be live
at about 10 10 p.m so sign up by going
to timcast.com clicking join us but
let's read your super chats we got
grafty who says pack that like button
we love those chickens
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
we appreciate the update on everything
today and the work you're doing to get
the social club going my offer still
stands if you need to help at all I look
forward to bluffing out a pot win so uh
cast Brew Coffee Cafe is is underway it
is in development we got a um what is it
called the voiceograph
one of the things that we have at the
coffee shop is this booth you can go
into and record a vinyl of yourself so
that's one of the things we're going to
have here at super fun uh you can sing
you can talk or whatever and then you'll
have a vinyl record of that recorded
audio very cool that's sick that does
sound cool so it's it's happening it's
getting built and then our coffee of
course that we're going to be selling
there is here and so we're gonna have
tons of this at the location we're going
to be carrying uh and this is true we're
gonna we're gonna have at the shop
Jeremy's chocolate bars we're gonna have
those like on the counter for people
when you're buying stuff as like an
Impulse Buy
so all of that's getting installed the
plumbing is getting installed second and
third floor social club we will probably
open really really really soon because
to open a social club we don't do
anything we literally just put a couch
and a TV in there and then say I don't
figure it out I want to come yeah figure
it out and um but what we want to do is
we want to have fun things to do so to
start obviously there'll be video games
there'll be movies we don't have a
liquor license so it'll be soft drinks
but you can you know order you know food
or whatever and just hang out creating a
community space for like-minded
individuals and an overlap where it will
be its own private business but a
courtesy to Tim cast members to come and
hang out and then the elite members for
this special third floor VIP but we want
to do poker with the boys the show on
the third floor
and oh boy am I learning a whole lot
about West Virginia law uh Pokemon and
Magic the Gathering are illegal under
West Virginia law and I'm not I'm not
being up I'm not good funny I'm not
being silly uh the law was drafted
before trading card games existed and so
the law literally says any card game or
table for any card game it doesn't
Define wagering money or making bets it
outright just as card games and I think
it's like I said uh card games are I
think the first card game was magic the
Gathering in the early 90s but poker
laws have been on the books going back
100 some odd years so they never
legalized the right to play any kind of
card game it was always viewed as
illegal gambling so I learned this
because when we were researching the law
we were told even playing poker for
nothing like a prop game where you just
everyone gets a set amount of chips no
one spends any money and you play for
fun is also considered illegal gaming if
a private business offers it and I'm
like well hold on there a minute there
are a bunch of places that offer a a
child can go into a game store give
twenty dollars play a card game in hopes
to win something of value which is
literally defined as illegal gambling in
West Virginia but they allow it so
that's that's what we're working on
right now and I spoke this is really
really funny because I spoke with the
government of West Virginia and I don't
want to drag anybody but the response I
got when I mentioned like what's what's
what's the legal reasoning for All For
You know these card shops that have
Yu-Gi-Oh magic and Pokemon card games
where a person will pay money to enter a
tournament play a game which includes
skill enchants and then win something of
value they said oh but that's all
regulated by the West Virginia Lottery
Commission and I was like you you think
these Pokemon tournaments are are
regulated under the West you think these
children these game shops are signing up
and buying lives they're not doing that
and he was like oh oh I don't know I
think it's just no one knew it was
happening under the radar it's not
because if it's not culturally enforced
who's going to what cop is going to go
to a Pokemon card game and be like card
games are illegal in this state sorry
but then so my argument is what is their
reasoning for allowing one but not the
other and I'll get there's another Super
Chat I'm gonna read later on and I'll
get more into detail but let's read some
more
Omega rasetsu says Tim the Federal
Reserve is partly owned by JPMorgan
Chase I don't think Chase will go belly
up due to the acquisition the FED will
bail out Chase then the question is why
didn't the FED bail out first Republic
and maybe for that reason but that says
to me something shady is going on and uh
that's just me if I had money with Chase
or a credit card I wouldn't use it
because I'd be scared that something
Shady was going on like they're trying
to use banking crisis as a vehicle to
implement a digital a central bank
digital currency in that if they can
seize Banks and then use federal money
to sell them to JP Morgan but get like
here's the thing the federal government
seizes the bank then gives JPMorgan
money then JP Morgan buys it from the
from the government that is not a
purchase that is a government seizure
and handing over of a bank with public
funds to a private entity sounds Shady
to me so here's the thing so it does
sound really shady are we at the point
of no return like haven't I mean how
would you even stop something like this
what could you even do like it's it's
gonna happen for me I just take my money
out of these I take my money out of
Chase I wonder if we're I wonder if the
point of no return is like the Event
Horizon of a black hole like do we pass
it and not know it like are we already
stressed yeah is it already
spaghettifying right right yeah
spaghettifying that's the scientific
term like sneaky like this
scientific term yeah but that's a that's
a real I know I'm just gonna say
spaghetti I think we're talking we're
talking to Peter bogosian when we was on
the show when we were in Austin he was
explaining he's like I'm not you know
saying this is an insult this is the
actual term biologists used yeah there
you go
what do we got here Jason Dixon says I
don't know what y'all did but the show
is so much better what have you all done
differently it's just the last week it's
just the last week this has happened I I
don't know something changed it feels
more
leprechauny you know what I mean like a
little like there's like the trolls I'm
a little bit of a leprechaun man you
know what I mean I have no idea what
that was do you have leprosy and I'm a
con man I thought it might be like
leprosy as well I've never seen I lied I
was just trying to compliment who
Sheamus oh this should be on a little
island thank you I I heard that I want
you all to know it's the nicest thing
Tim's ever said to me I heard that it
involved insulting me I heard you went
on a podcast and the guy gave you a
potato yes I was on Pines with Aquinas
and Matt frad that dirty dog shout out
to Mad Fred what I told him to name the
uh the episode Matt and Sheamus waste
five hours because literally we wasted
five hours we yeah I I did his longest
podcast ever at four hours and then
George farmer uh beat that time so we
had to beat it and we should have edited
it like three and a half hours and we
just we we we wasted a lot of time don't
but he gave you a potential but he and
he gave me a potato and it was really
hurtful and I stormed out yeah hurtful
yeah it was very hurtful if someone gave
me a potato I'd be like oh thank you you
know what really always bother me I have
two then I can have dinner you know the
saying if life gives you lemons you make
lemonade or if gives you potato makeup
if life gives me lemons I go oh wow I
love lemons thank you life lemons are
fantastic I can put it on my fish I can
put it on some oysters or whatever you
know what's really like lemonade I can
make lemons right off the lemon tree
they're sweet oh you don't have to add
sugar they're just delicious absolutely
when I was in Greece I was in Crete and
we were like picking lemons off this
lemon tree before these guys came out of
the monastery and started shooting at us
because apparently we weren't supposed
to touch the monasteries lemon tree I
didn't realize shooting whatever it
things happen but we absconded with a
good couple of lemons when they were
delicious when life gives you lemon
lemons you say thank you life These are
delicious
lemons you run away from the man
shooting at you whatever it happens all
right here we go
um Robert Knight says it's a culmination
I've been talking about since January
they're consolidating deposits into a
few major Banks to make transition to
Fed now and future cbdc easier also debt
limit cap happens in June that's what
I'm saying this guy knows he knows
better than I do I'm like this this
banking collapse stuff is is how they
Implement a central bank digital
currency your bank goes belly up and
then they say we've rescued your money
just download fednow on the App Store
and all of your deposit has been
converted to Fed coin which you can use
to make any purchase it's the same as US
Dollars this is what I'm saying I hate
it but how can we stop it don't don't
like
I don't want to give anybody Financial
advice sure okay I'll tell you what I'm
gonna do okay I am taking my money away
from institutions that are engaged in
this kind of practice I'm investing in
things like Bitcoin currency uh Bitcoin
and cryptocurrency uh and investing in
in land and stuff like that and trying
to have a decent amount of uh
physical dollars as well as gold silver
and other precious metals in the
physical world
other than that I'm looking at physical
assets yeah but things that are
considered to be of monetary exchange
like a silver coin can be traded with
someone as a universal uh you know
holder of value but other than that
there's also items that we may consider
to be something that'll appreciate in
value what is a household item that may
become hard to get that you would want
to have that is good for trade value
so what is hard to manufacture
primers eggs primers are impossible to
get primer primers no I'm thinking about
primers for for uh for uh for a bullet
yeah
bullets because didn't Biden illegalize
or make illegal incandescent light bulbs
oh I don't know maybe for the better
light but uh I mean look at this Dan
Gingrich is the same thing the bank
crisis is intentional to reduce the
number of banks controlling the money so
they can more easily Institute Central
Bank digital currency and use that to
Institute more control over the
population you see you see these we got
smart people here watching this show
they know what's up
voice of the people is a serious
question why invest in crypto if they
control digital currency with EO 14067
and control the internet with a restrict
act blocking access to to markets while
finding millions and imprisoning for VPN
use and assets
because you can
with Bitcoin being decentralized I'm not
telling you to buy any
they can control certain points of
access but they can never control the
decentralized network which stores your
value and then you can always find some
means of connecting to it or you can
store the crypto in in cold storage and
then physically transfer to somebody in
exchange for something they've made
they've done transfers with all sorts of
mediums you can send you can literally
send like physical mail with the code to
change oh really yeah you could you just
have to send someone your private key if
you want to send the send a Bitcoin so I
mean you can do all sorts of uh
interesting and creative
uh ways to transfer Bitcoin that are not
directly on chain oh look at this um
Donald devoll says it gives me a
headache anyways but Barons reports Bud
Light sales fell 26 due to the backlash
wow interesting
I always get so nervous that like the
things I like are going to end up
getting caught up in all these uh
dumb controversies and I'm gonna have to
not buy them anymore I hate that I have
Nikes and stuff that I'm like I can't
even wear these anymore at least I can't
wear them here because I know that the
chat will just you wore that shirt that
one time I know I've got a I got a Nike
hat and a couple pair of Nike shoes I'm
never wearing them again uh the lion
says Phil I was at work by my by myself
Saturday didn't feel like listening to
podcasts wanted some music put on some
All That Remains you got a new fan bud
sick thank you I appreciate it there you
go
Wishbone says JP Morgan and City won't
fail until the dollar does JP has the
military-industrial complex and the dod
travel money goes through city they're
centralizing it
interesting
sevi Rose says Grandpa Tell us again
about the Bud Light Wars all right
children gather around will I tell you
about a beer that everyone hated but
fought over anyway
that's why it was so easy to win because
Bud Light was never good to begin with
no nobody wanted to drink it now they
have a reason to be like I'm not
drinking it definitely not easiest
boycott I ever did I quit drinking years
ago
I just don't understand why people drink
it that way of course like the Blackhawk
war no one remembers the Blackhawk War
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah Lincoln was
involved in that
I was uh uh at an event and uh I had a
Yingling it tastes good I like it I like
delicious I don't like I don't like
drinking all that much but you know
what do we got here we got the DD Mega
doodoo says the shimus and full episode
is the one I've been waiting for now we
need to have James Lindsay and the two
of you on together
I want to hang out
Brado uh Jacko says the goal of the FED
is to collapse all smaller Banks so cbdc
can be easily forced by the few huge fed
Banks like Goldman that are allowed to
remain they'll collapse and consolidate
and then the big banks will collapse and
they'll say
here's what's going to happen
they're hoping that someone like me
looking at our business at timcast sees
our operating account collapse because
our bank goes under and then they want
me to either say we have to do this
otherwise I can't pay my employees or
cease to exist because we can't pay our
employees that's what that's how it'll
happen it is being forced in One
Direction
plan for it accordingly by talking to a
financial advisor you trust today which
ain't me buy guns
satosha cater Gator says cheers from
Vegas I love poker it's day four of
being a Sheamus fan by the way y'all
should check out speechless by Michael
are you in are you in are you in Vegas
for the World Series of Poker that's uh
I think that's starting now-ish or
something like that they were having the
World Poker Tour in Florida that's why
that guy joined the ladies event
uh so that was kicked ass yeah he showed
those ladies how to play that's great
the funny thing though is like he was a
random guy who just showed up while all
these women were actually there to
compete I mean the jokes just made it
right themselves yeah isn't that crazy
kind of does it that one yeah
step aside ladies
all right let's uh I'm gonna grab I want
to grab this super chat right here from
yeah but Trump cause uh
you got some fighting words there sir he
says Tim how much did you pay for the
power nine cards in your decks how much
did you pay for the aces in a deck you
don't own how much thought did you put
into a Pokemon deck Magic the Gathering
is BattleBots poker is throwing darts at
balloons at a carnival no comparison
you're right there is no comparison
Magic the Gathering Pokemon Yu-Gi-Oh Etc
are more chance based than poker is I
would as someone who's played Magic the
Gathering since I was like eight or nine
years old since uh Antiquities or
whatever said it was barely had any idea
what I was doing back then and has
played all the way up till now with a
bunch of Commander decks some that have
extremely rare cards I do not have power
nine power nine cards those aren't
familiar are some of the most expensive
Magic Gathering cards in existence
costing thousands of dollars and they're
extremely rare and so here's my point
about magic the Gathering
in Magic the Gathering for those that
aren't familiar it is one of the most
popular strategy card games ever it was
the first when the game starts you draw
seven cards at random from a shuffled
deck the game has spell cards and
resource cards uh oh if you don't draw
the correct amount of resource cards you
lose the game outright okay no not
completely there's something called the
Mulligan but the likelihood you can win
if you don't have a good draw starts
dropping dramatically to the point where
several Pro players would just concede
the game outright if they had two bad
draws back to back
in poker a hand is only a single portion
a shuffle of a deck and a deal of the
cards is a tiny portion of the game and
it's free no joke you can sit down at a
poker table at a casino and spend no
money and they will give you cards you
can then look at them and say these are
not good cards I'm not going to play
this one hand you can do that about five
times before you have to actually pay
what's called a blind or you can get up
and leave and never pay anything
with magic the Gathering and Pokemon and
Yu-Gi-Oh you pay the man at the cart the
game shop the card shop a 20 entry fee
that money goes towards the prize pool
you then cross your fingers and hope you
get a good draw and if you do you might
have a better chance of winning then
pointing at the Power Nine even more
random chance I can't when I was a kid I
couldn't afford to buy any of those
cards that meant my cards are always
going to be garbage and my likelihood of
winning was extremely low that's not
skill that's just buying in the rich
kids had better decks this is why I like
poker so much having been someone who's
played magic my whole life there it's
completely equal footing and the game is
based on whether or not you can figure
out what your opponent is doing and
whether or not you like it's not it's
not even not even about cards I'll tell
you this I played this weekend and I got
a garbage hand and I ended up winning
against someone who probably had me beat
because I played it better in Magic the
Gathering and Pokemon which I think are
fantastic games and they're skill based
for sure but my argument is there's just
more random chance in those than in poke
simply put Holden style games PLO Etc
should be legal and so should Pokemon in
Magic and it's just I think it's
discriminatory that these states and
many states are allowing one game and
not the other
I'll wrap it up there but I can I can go
into great detail and talk about why I
think it shouldn't be that way
well it's we will read some more Super
chats from you
Kelly Ward says thank you Libby they
make fun of the products that were a
little traumatizing when I was younger I
was 19 before I even bought my own
tampons they have no idea what they're
mocking
oh it's awful it's so awful to have to
go into the store and buy tampons and
carry them up to the front and like
stand you stand there and they're like
by your side and you hope nobody looks
at you BS I've done it for girls and
it's not that big of a deal it's not a
big deal if you're a fella doing it for
girls but if you're a girl you're
walking up there you're like now
everyone knows what's going on with my
body it feels weird really and they used
to do this thing at drugstores where
they would like double bag it in a brown
bag so that you could walk out and
nobody would have to see what you're
carrying home with you now you have to
pay double for the bags now you have to
pay for the bags and they only give you
the plastic bags half the time and
everybody can see right through it I
find the whole thing humiliating the
real Hydro PX with an embarrassing
humiliating the real Hydro PX with an
embarrassingly ignorant uh Super Chat
says Tim does this all the time he
becomes an expert on anything he does
you will always pay if you're small
blind and big blind Tim knows it all
he's completely wrong uh when you go to
a poker table anywhere and sit down they
will say do you want to buy the button
or wait for it to pass
there's something called a forced bat in
poker where it's let's say you're
playing a game it's called one two a
small blind is one the big blind is two
dollars if you want to buy the button
you have to pay three dollars that means
that you are entering the game right at
the point and you will the button is the
dealer button that goes around the table
determining which whose turn it is and
who plays it first and who's playing who
plays last
if you sit down at a poker table you can
say I will wait for the button to pass
and you pay zero dollars you will then
be dealt hands when the button comes
around the table each hand dealt it
moves one space as soon as the blinds
come to your right you stand up and say
I am now leaving thank you for letting
me play with you and you've not paid a
single penny real Hydro you are
completely wrong and it's embarrassing
it's really really embarrassing I mean
just man wow I can't believe how
embarrassing it must be for you all
right let's read some more Super chats
uh what was it what do we got here uh
Captain Caveman says noodles is woke if
woke was a person
yes embarrassingly woke poor noodles
poor noodles oh yeah it was Clapper of
cheeks who said please look at Noodles
soy reaction to kiss Clapper of cheeks
soy reaction
Jake Swift says Atlanta Barman here
someone told me this weekend he'd rather
choke down a Miller High Life than have
Ultra because of Anheuser beers isn't it
yes he didn't seem politically motivated
but maybe trying too hard to be
masculine you see that's what I'm
talking about
guys who drink beers do sometimes tend
to be
try too hard to be masculine you think
that's right that sometimes because if
they were really masculine they'd be
drinking whiskey they'd be drinking
strawberry daiquiris because they'd be
secure
sexuality I tell you what I can't hate
on a peach Bellini man I love my page
that one gamer says is Ian returning
anytime soon I disagree with him but
he's a pretty chill guy oh he he's uh
he's a he's the new co-host for Alex
Stein's show he's no longer here he's
going he and Ian just he's he left he
packed his bags what happened is he had
a he had a stick with a handkerchief
tied up at the end of it with a couple
things in there and he said I'm going
and he left any hitchhikes maybe he
hopped a freight train that's right he's
got bogus in the uh yeah
[Laughter]
oh my gosh he'll be back soon Ian's
downstairs literally talked to him this
morning yeah yeah he was all excited
he's like we got to work on stuff man
I'm really excited it's gonna be great
uh real Hydro he's got a response he
says if there are two people on the
table they can play for free no your
claim is only right if the table is full
duh that's what I said the button goes
around so you can play five hands for
free jeez man these people don't even
understand and then someone mentioned um
we got zillazilla says poker rooms
charge time limit on games not Rick it's
called time rake and uh depending on the
table some some doing some don't uh at
MGM I just learned this the it's called
the 510 table that means the small blind
is five bucks the big blind is 10 bucks
no rake crazy no Rick a rake is when you
when the pot in the middle of money the
dealer takes a portion out for the
casino itself
it sucks oh interesting over a long
enough period of time every player will
lose because the money going back and
forth will keep getting smaller and if
you play long enough you will notice
everyone's chips are going down
you play at the higher Stakes table and
they do what's called a Time rake every
half an hour a new dealer sits down you
pay the dealer seven dollars and then
play the game blinds are forced bats you
got to pay those my point is simply this
at any table you can play about five
hands at a full ring without paying any
money and you can't do that for any
Magic Gathering tournament with steaks
you have to pay up front to the the
owner of the shop that money goes
towards the prize pool and the house
takes a cut of it for their profit
that's no different from raking in a
poker game and here's the other thing in
the law a wager is a bet that someone
will win and this is in West Virginia
that's interesting which means when
you're playing Pokemon Yugioh or magic
when you buy into the tournament you are
saying I am buying in to enter Because I
will win these games and then get the
cash prize in poker a bet is not a
determination that you are going to win
if I've got a good hand or bad hand
whatever and then I say I make it
fifteen dollars I am not wagering that
I'm going to win I am saying if you
would like to continue playing you must
all also put forth fifteen dollars I
don't know who's gonna win I don't know
if I have the best cards and I'm not
betting I do I'm simply saying that's
the cost to keep playing and if someone
might say I don't want to keep playing
you win and you can have the worst cards
and win in that game
not gambling
and I don't think Pokemon Yu-Gi-Oh magic
should be regulated as gambling either
I'm simply making the point that the
legal arguments are nonsense
but let's read more
what do we got in the old super jets
Rusty razor says Tim two of the three
big bank failures are San Francisco
Regional Banks maybe it isn't the
banking something that's failing maybe
it's the tech sector
yeah but the um uh uh the First Republic
this was you know billionaires like
people were buying big assets on um
crazy loans
so it is it is Silicon Valley I get it
all right Brandon Devore says as a magic
player in Tim's defense look up how many
Magic Pros have gone to Poker it's not
even gone to tons of Magic the Gathering
professional players are simultaneously
professional poker players and having
played magic most of my life I think I
think poker is a better game because
there's less what we would call variants
people call it gambling Saints game of
chance no it's just variants in the game
but if you know how to navigate the odds
of the game and what people are going to
do and when they're doing it then I I
look at I look at Magic the Gathering
with like pros of a win rate of 51 to
like your average poker Pros win rate is
90 plus percent and I'm just like come
on man don't even don't even bring that
stuff to me and I like magic the
Gathering it's fun I got a whole bunch
of cards
Nuka Taco says you post big blind to get
cards in a cash game only if you want to
buy the button at first or if you wait
until the big blind comes to you like I
said you can wait for the button to pass
play the cards for free then get up and
leave
because people do it I don't know
whatever
Michael Otis says Tim have you heard of
the artist Ren his song High Ren is is
by far one of the most emotionally
moving songs I've heard or highly
recommend a listen
very cool
Robert Knight says Tim I just put the
rest of the puzzle together they'll use
a bank bail uh Bank bail bail in to pay
off Bank debts then issue the FED cbdc
as a replacement for the depositors it's
going to start to unfold over the summer
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying
all right
real Hydro says Tim can you name the top
female chess player no I can't how about
the top male Magnus Carlson that's easy
come on stop looking down on women we
are not the same yes there is a small
handful of top female chess players but
they they don't reach the same levels as
men there's a small handful of top
female poker players that that there's
some that make it and some that don't
put oh it's overwhelmingly male and like
all of these Sports I don't I don't know
what the point trying to be made is
because I'm not saying women are bad for
not being the best at these things I'm
just saying men tend to win therefore
there's a reason why we have a women's
league in immensely
Robert Bradbury says the greatest thing
about New Hampshire is the wild turkeys
we have wild turkeys all over our
property it's great they walk around and
the dudes their wings like fall down and
their butts puff up but then they can
also shrink back down it's people are I
I feel like City people get confused and
they see wild turkeys because they don't
understand they just look like regular
Birds because they're used to seeing the
Thanksgiving pictures of the big turkey
with its tail all spread out and puffed
up and looking big well in New Hampshire
those are wandering around they do here
too but when the males shrink back down
they puff up to look big and threatening
and then they'll strain down and
turkey's fly
yes yes
yeah turkey's fly man yeah last summer I
remember seeing turkeys wandering around
the streets in New Hampshire
there was a turkey that tried to get
into a fight with his reflection in my
car one time no way oh yeah wow that's
kind of cool they're stupid as hell MJ's
got the good Super Chat right here says
hey Tim where can we play poker with you
so uh
for the past couple of weekends we have
been in uh MGM National Harbor and uh
before that it's uh Maryland Live we
used to play all the time at Hollywood
Charlestown until I stacked a guy in
such a in such a way that he got so
angry what happened so Hollywood
Charlestown is it's the West Virginia
Casino uh he tried bluffing me I guess
he kept he kept raising his bluff on the
you know he he raises pre-flop I guess
he had nothing I don't know then he uh
he raises on the Flop and I'm calling
him I had Ace King off suit and so I
just I see this flop and it's like I
think it was just like low cards all
different suits and I'm like this guy
doesn't have anything he's just throwing
money at the table trying to scare me
off So eventually he shoves his whole
stack and it's 300 because it's a it's a
100 300 game those are the buy-ins and
then I'm just like I'm sitting there
thinking and I'm like I got an Ace King
it's like the best non-paired hand and I
don't think he made anything so I call
then he's like I don't have anything he
flips over nothing and I say I got a
nice and then they shove all his chips
my way he got so pissed off he leaves
well he lost all his money he comes back
half an hour later that's cussing me out
like crazy when I asked them to just
move the guy and get him out of my face
they told me no they weren't going to do
anything about it and too bad and I was
like okay I'm not gonna play her anymore
that's insane and I think the issue is
their their poker room has been like
kind of shrinking and falling apart I
could be wrong about that but it's like
a lot smaller no one plays there anymore
so they're kind of desperate to to
retain players so they were like please
don't fight we're gonna let him keep
doing this and I'm just I'm out so uh MJ
National Harbor is a lot of fun and I
also noticed a lot of people there know
who I am so it's really cool people are
like oh hey man you know and they're
like fist bump me or something so that's
a whole lot of fun
and uh yeah I appreciate the support so
you might see me there on the weekends
if you're ever in the DC area it's a
Maryland Casino you know Maryland Live
is cool though you know it's all these
Maryland casinos all right we'll grab
one more here Elias Muniz says is it
possible that the JP Morgan first public
bio has something to do with the Jeffrey
Epstein JP connection government may
have told them they will sink their own
ship to stop people from finding out no
I think it's this essential Bank digital
currency thing I think it is all right
everybody we got a crazy members only
uncensored show coming up so go to
timcast.com become a member watch that
it's gonna be up in about 10 minutes and
we're gonna be talking about some crazy
stuff DeSantis has done
to uh people who are bad to children
and it's uh good for him so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast Olivia
you want to shout anything out yeah I'm
Libby Emmons you can follow me on
Twitter at Libby Emmons and you can
subscribe to the post-millennial and
human events at thepostmillennial.com
subscribe we have a lot of great people
Jack besobic Andy no Charlie Kirk
Savannah Hernandez Katie Davis Court I'm
there every day so um come check it out
I'm Seamus Coughlin the only thing I
want to plug tonight is St Joseph it's
the feast of Saint Joseph the Worker if
you all are interested I'm going to be
praying a novena to St Joseph for the
working class in this country in this
very tumultuous economy for The Unborn
for whatever difficult times that Leia
had to help our country return to God
and for our enemies people like Dylan
Mulvaney and other trans ideologues that
they will will see the light and be
converted I think Trump said it better
when he said Merry Christmas to
everybody even the haters the losers
let's pray for them and let's let's also
of course we were joking earlier but
pray for the people at Vice who are out
of work as well
uh today I uh I'm Philippine oh by the
way I'm so sorry the link is on my
Twitter if you guys want to go find my
Twitter the link to the Novena I am
Philip remains uh on Twitter I'm Philip
remains official on Instagram the band
is All That Remains on Spotify Apple
music Etc today is victims of Communism
day it's May 1st
um about a hundred million people or so
died uh because of communist countries
and uh today is a day that we remember
uh the victims of Communism so
I wanted to point that out and uh I'm
search.com I also dislike communism a
great deal it is not cool just a quick
reminder communism is not cool uh that's
all uh argue with me on Twitter at
surge.com peace guys all right everybody
we will see you over at timcast.com in
about 10 minutes for the uncensored
members only show where maybe you will
be calling in and talking to all of us
and hanging out so thanks for hanging
out and we will see you all there